Hidden Brain visited 16 cities with our perceptions tour in 2025, and we're excited to visit even more communities across the U.S. this year. We'll have more announcements about tour stops in the months to come. For now, I want to make sure you know about two live shows that are coming up soon. I'll be in Philadelphia at the Miller Theater on March 21st and at the town hall in New York City on March 25th. For tickets to either show, go to Hiddenbrain.org slash tour. That's hiddenbrain.org slash tour.
Hidden Brain 在 2025 年带着我们的“感知之旅”走访了 16 个城市，我们很高兴今年能走访美国更多的社区。在接下来的几个月里，我们将发布更多关于巡演站点的信息。现在，我想确保你们知道即将举行的两场现场演出。我将于 3 月 21 日在费城的米勒剧院，以及 3 月 25 日在纽约市的市政厅进行演出。如需购买这两场演出的门票，请访问 Hiddenbrain.org/tour。网址是 hiddenbrain.org/tour。
I hope to see you there. Okay, here's today's show. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. In a famous Chinese parable, a man frustrated with all of his failures exiles himself to the woods. There, he meets a hermit with whom he shares his frustrations. Give me one good reason not to quit, the man tells the hermit. The hermit points to a tall patch of foliage.
希望能在那里见到你们。好了，这是今天的节目。我是 Shankar Vedantam。在一则著名的中国寓言中，一个对所有失败感到沮丧的男人将自己流放到森林里。在那里，他遇到了一位隐士，并向他倾诉了自己的挫折。男人对隐士说：“给我一个不放弃的理由。”隐士指向了一片高大的树丛。
You see this bamboo? he asks. I nurtured it for a year and it did not grow as much as an inch. But the hermit did not give up. The second year, he waters and nurtures the plot again. Nothing. A third year goes by. Again nothing. year four the same by the fifth year the hermit says a tiny sprout emerged from the earth and within six months the tree grew a hundred feet tall
“你看到这些竹子了吗？”他问道，“我培育了它一年，它连一英寸都没长。但隐士没有放弃。第二年，他再次浇水和培育这块地。什么都没有。第三年过去了。还是什么都没有。第四年也一样。到了第五年，隐士说，大地中冒出了一株小芽，在六个月内，这棵树长到了一百英尺高。”
during all those years when it appeared that nothing was happening the bamboo was growing underground hidden from view it had been rapidly spreading roots all the time you had been struggling the hermit told the man you were growing strong roots in the Parable, the man learns his lesson and the value of persistence. He goes back to his life and continues his pursuits. It's beautiful, isn't it? This idea that we think we're getting nowhere, but our efforts might be paying off in ways we cannot see. Yet, it also raises an uncomfortable problem. How can you tell the difference between growing roots underground
“在那些看起来什么都没发生的岁月里，竹子其实是在地下生长，隐藏在视线之外。它一直在迅速地蔓延根系。你挣扎的时候，其实是在长出强壮的根。”隐士告诉那个男人。在寓言中，男人学到了教训和坚持的价值。他回到自己的生活中，继续追求自己的目标。这很美，不是吗？我们以为自己一事无成，但我们的努力可能正以我们看不见的方式获得回报。然而，这也提出了一个令人不安的问题。你如何分辨是在地下扎根，
and when you're simply watering and nurturing a dead plot of land? Today on the show, we explore the conundrum of people. patience when it makes sense to persist even when you can't see what's happening below the surface and when we should be impatient. Also, practical ways we can learn to be more patient, even in trying circumstances. Learning to wait this week on Hidden Brain. From a young age, we are taught to be patient. Sit still. Wait quietly. Hold off eating one marshmallow in order to enjoy two later on. When we become adults, with more power over how many marshmallows we can have, patience often falls by the wayside.
还是仅仅在给一块死地浇水和培育？今天在节目中，我们将探讨耐心的难题。什么时候坚持是有意义的，即使你看不见地表下发生了什么；以及我们什么时候应该失去耐心。此外，我们还将探讨在困难的情况下，学习如何变得更有耐心的实用方法。本周在 Hidden Brain 节目中，学习等待。从小，我们就被教导要耐心。坐好。安静地等待。为了以后能享受两颗棉花糖，先忍住不吃一颗。当我们成年后，对能拥有多少棉花糖有了更多的掌控权，耐心往往就被抛诸脑后了。
At Baylor University, psychologist Sarah Schnitker studies the science of patients. She says that being patient may be a lost skill for many of us, but it's also one that's frequently misunderstood. Sarah Schnitker, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me today. Sarah, in 2012, a quarterback for the Washington, D.C. football team, team was injured during a game against the Baltimore Ravens. What happened to Robert Griffin III, or RG3, as he was called?
在贝勒大学，心理学家 Sarah Schnitker 研究耐心的科学。她说，对我们许多人来说，耐心可能是一项失传的技能，但它也经常被误解。Sarah Schnitker，欢迎来到 Hidden Brain。非常感谢你今天邀请我。Sarah，2012 年，华盛顿特区橄榄球队的一名四分卫在对阵巴尔的摩乌鸦队的比赛中受伤。罗伯特·格里芬三世（Robert Griffin III），也就是人们所说的 RG3，发生了什么事？
Yes, RG3, Baylor's hometown hero. What happened in that game is that he was tackled, and they took him off the field, said, no, we're not going to play the rest of the game. They brought in Kirk Cousins, able to actually win the game. But RG3 really sustained this tough injury. RG3. Now it looks like he's hurt his right leg. I mean, this would be devastating. You can watch his right leg. He's going to get... Oh, that didn't look good. So the next day was confirmed that he had a sprain, and RG3 was asked to sit out the next game to heal.
是的，RG3，贝勒大学的家乡英雄。在那场比赛中，他被擒抱，他们把他抬下场，说：“不，我们不会让他参加剩下的比赛了。”他们换上了柯克·考辛斯（Kirk Cousins），他实际上赢得了比赛。但 RG3 确实受了严重的伤。RG3。现在看起来他伤到了右腿。我的意思是，这太令人震惊了。你可以看他的右腿。他要……哦，那看起来不太好。所以第二天证实他扭伤了，RG3 被要求缺席下一场比赛以进行康复。
But the team's head coach reported that the star quarterback had been medically cleared to play. So he came back in that game to success. But all was not well with his knee, was it? No, all was not well. And the team did. doctor who had supposedly medically cleared him has since then said, no, I did not clear him. He should not have been playing. And I think there was just this immense pressure for our G3 to move back in. He was the superstar. He was this rookie sensation. The Heisman Trophy winner. He was all this energy behind him. And the coach and team just wanted him out there. The fans wanted him out there as well. I remember reading the newspapers in Washington, D.C. at the time.
但球队主教练报告说，这位明星四分卫已在医疗上获准上场。所以他回到了那场比赛并取得了成功。但他的膝盖情况并不好，对吧？不，情况并不好。而球队那位据称在医疗上批准他上场的医生后来表示：“不，我没有批准他。他不应该上场。”我认为当时有一种巨大的压力迫使 RG3 回归。他是超级巨星。他是新秀轰动人物。海斯曼奖得主。他背后有所有的能量。教练和球队只是想让他上场。球迷们也想让他上场。我记得当时读华盛顿特区的报纸。
And, you know, there was incredible excitement about R.G.3 coming to town. The Washington football team had not been a good team for a long time. And the belief was that he was going to turn everything around. And, you know, everywhere he went, he was treated like the, you know, like the second coming of the Messiah. Indeed. Indeed, he was. And I think in the United States and especially in our sports stories, we love. recovery story that someone gets injured and they show this amazing grit and push through and come out of it.
你知道，人们对 RG3 的到来感到无比兴奋。华盛顿橄榄球队已经很久没有成为一支强队了。人们相信他会扭转一切。而且，你知道，无论他走到哪里，他都被视为救世主的再临。确实。确实如此。我认为在美国，尤其是在我们的体育故事中，我们热爱复活的故事，即某人受伤后展现出惊人的毅力，克服困难并走出来。
And so I think this narrative of this superstar, almost superhuman, who can instantly recover, was pushing RG3 to come back. So he came back that same season to some success. But later on this season, during a wild card game in January of the following year, things took a turn for the worst. What happened, Sarah? Yes, things took a turn for the worst indeed. And he was tackled again, and he re-injured his LCL. And he also tore a reconstructed ACL. And this is pretty devastating.
所以我认为这种超级巨星、近乎超人、能够瞬间康复的叙事，一直在推动 RG3 回归。所以他在同一个赛季回归并取得了一些成功。但后来在这个赛季，在次年一月的季后赛外卡赛中，情况变得更糟了。发生了什么，Sarah？是的，情况确实变得更糟了。他再次被擒抱，并再次伤到了外侧副韧带（LCL）。他还撕裂了重建后的前交叉韧带（ACL）。这非常令人震惊。
I actually remember the fans at the time just being so sad that this rookie quarterback who was seen kind of as the Messiah of the team was injured. again and had to sit out that season. So he ended up getting reconstructive surgery in the off-season. But of course, a few months later, the new season began. RG3 was encouraged to rush back into his starting role. Even though he had not played a single game in the preseason, Adidas even got behind his return with a campaign all in for week one.
我实际上记得当时的球迷们非常难过，因为这位被视为球队救世主的新秀四分卫再次受伤，不得不缺席那个赛季。所以他在休赛期接受了重建手术。但当然，几个月后，新赛季开始了。RG3 被鼓励匆忙回到首发位置。尽管他在季前赛中没有参加过一场比赛，阿迪达斯甚至通过“All In for Week One”的活动支持他的回归。
It's wild to me how intense this became. And I mean, I think in many ways it's unheard of to have. your first game back be on week one and not do any preseason. And what you saw on that game was exactly what you'd expect that this person was not ready. They were getting tackled a lot. That there was not that speed and agility. The RG3 needed more time to recover and needed more time to practice before going out into a real live game. And you saw them throughout that year, never really got back to his condition that he was in when he began as a rookie the year before. And in many ways, this is a tragic story, Sarah, because again, RG3 entered the football league
这对我来说太疯狂了，变得如此激烈。我的意思是，我认为在很多方面，第一场比赛就直接上场而不参加任何季前赛是闻所未闻的。你在那场比赛中看到的正是你所预料的：这个人还没有准备好。他被擒抱了很多次。没有那种 RG3 在进入真实比赛前所需要的速度和敏捷性。他需要更多的时间来恢复，需要更多的时间来练习。你在那一年里看到他，他从未真正回到他前一年作为新秀开始时的状态。在很多方面，这是一个悲剧性的故事，Sarah，因为 RG3 进入橄榄球联盟时
with just such incredible promise and hype. What became of his career? Well, you know, he He never really performed the way that was hoped. And on social media, said he regrets his decision to go back so quickly and wishes he had taken the time because he might have had a different career. I know I shouldn't have played that year. But when you're a player and you're in fight or flight mode, you're always going to choose to fight. Sometimes we want something so bad that we're willing to hurt ourselves for it.
带着如此令人难以置信的前景和炒作。他的职业生涯后来怎么样了？嗯，你知道，他从未真正表现出人们所希望的那样。他在社交媒体上说，他后悔自己决定那么快回归，并希望自己当时能花点时间，因为他可能会有不同的职业生涯。“我知道我不应该在那一年上场。但当你是一名球员，处于‘战斗或逃跑’模式时，你总是会选择战斗。”有时我们太想要某样东西，以至于愿意为此伤害自己。
But there's a difference between doing something because you love it. and doing the smart thing. Let's go from the world of sports to politics. In 2003, Howard Dean, a former governor of Vermont, announced his bid to become the Democratic presidential nominee for the 2004 election. He was an early critic of the U.S. war in Iraq at a time when the war was still popular.
但因为热爱而做某事与做明智的事情之间是有区别的。让我们从体育界转向政界。2003 年，佛蒙特州前州长霍华德·迪恩（Howard Dean）宣布竞选 2004 年大选的民主党总统候选人提名。在伊拉克战争仍然受欢迎的时候，他是美国对伊战争的早期批评者。
Talk about how he wrote a wave of anti-war sentiment among Democratic Party voters, especially younger voters, Sarah. He got this huge, incredible, early lead from this energy and really had such a grassroots up swelling that people were excited, they were eager. He just went into Iowa with all this energy and excitement. There was a U.S. Senator who called Dean the Harry Truman of our time, the kind of plain spoken Democrat that we need. So he had a lot of enthusiasm behind him. What happened in that Iowa caucus? Oh, the Iowa caucus, it did not go so well for him. His main rivals, John Kerry, John Edwards, they really outperformed him. He came out third, and he might have been able to recover from that. But there is this infamous speech he gave that night after coming in third that many say may have doomed him.
谈谈他是如何利用民主党选民，尤其是年轻选民中反战情绪的浪潮的，Sarah。他凭借这种能量获得了巨大的、令人难以置信的早期领先优势，并确实引发了草根阶层的涌动，人们感到兴奋，他们渴望改变。他带着所有的能量和兴奋进入了爱荷华州。有一位美国参议员称迪恩为“我们时代的哈里·杜鲁门”，是我们需要的那种直言不讳的民主党人。所以他背后有很多热情。爱荷华州党团会议上发生了什么？哦，爱荷华州党团会议，对他来说进行得并不顺利。他的主要竞争对手约翰·克里（John Kerry）和约翰·爱德华兹（John Edwards）的表现确实超过了他。他获得了第三名，他本可以从那次失败中恢复过来。但那天晚上获得第三名后，他发表了一次臭名昭著的演讲，许多人说这可能注定了他的失败。
So this was on January 19, 2004. Dean and his supporters gathered at the Val Air Ballroom in West Des Moines, Iowa. And what he was looking to do was not just to concede Iowa, but to quickly reignite the enthusiasm of his supporters. What happened, Sarah? Well, his supporters were really enthusiastic at this speech. So he started yelling louder and louder. Now, unfortunately,
这是在 2004 年 1 月 19 日。迪恩和他的支持者聚集在爱荷华州西得梅因的 Val Air 舞厅。他想要做的不仅仅是承认在爱荷华州的失败，而是迅速重新点燃支持者的热情。发生了什么，Sarah？嗯，他的支持者在这次演讲中确实非常热情。所以他开始喊得越来越响。现在，不幸的是，
The TV viewers who are watching this could not actually hear just how loud the crowd was. And so as he begins to shout over these cheers and get louder and louder, he starts to sound a little bit unhinged. And he ends with this full-throated kind of scream. We're going to Washington, D.C. to take back the White House. To me, it sounds like a dying goat. And this final, yeah, became known as the Dean scream or the I Have a Scream speech. But this was just replayed over and over on the news and really undermine kind of the seriousness of his candidacy. I think he was trying very quickly to get his supporters turned around after this defeat.
观看电视的观众实际上听不到人群有多大声。所以当他开始在这些欢呼声中大喊大叫，声音越来越大时，他开始听起来有点精神失常。他以一种全力的尖叫结束了演讲：“我们要去华盛顿特区，夺回白宫！”对我来说，这听起来像一只垂死的山羊。而这最后的“Yeah”被称为“迪恩尖叫”或“我有一个尖叫”演讲。但这在新闻中被反复播放，确实削弱了他候选资格的严肃性。我认为他当时正试图在这次失败后迅速扭转支持者的情绪。
And I think part of the problem was a mismatch between how urgent he felt the situation, was and how urgent the situation actually was. Indeed. And, you know, sometimes when you have a loss or defeat, it's actually okay to take a few moments and lick your wounds to just take the time, heal a little bit. But you see when you watch this video that he just wanted everyone to be pumped up and have that same energy that he had a week before Iowa. And instead of kind of letting that loss take its course and then come back,
我认为问题的一部分在于他感受到的紧迫感与局势实际的紧迫感之间存在错位。确实。而且，你知道，有时当你遭受损失或失败时，花点时间舔舐伤口，花点时间稍微愈合一下，其实是可以的。但当你观看这段视频时，你会发现他只是想让每个人都兴奋起来，拥有他一周前在爱荷华州时拥有的那种能量。而不是让那种损失顺其自然，然后再回来，
He just wanted instantly to push back into that energy and excitement and that kind of winning celebration mode. But he wasn't there. And so the scream just encapsulates that. I want to talk about one other case of impatience that had serious consequences, Sarah. We've all heard the phrase fail fast. Companies are often encouraged to rush their products to market and to fix problems later on. In 2016, Samsung rushed to release their new phone. the Galaxy Note 7, they wanted to beat Apple's release of the iPhone 7.
他只是想立刻推回到那种能量和兴奋以及那种胜利庆祝模式中。但他当时并不处于那种状态。所以尖叫声恰恰概括了这一点。我想谈谈另一个导致严重后果的缺乏耐心的案例，Sarah。我们都听过“快速失败”（fail fast）这个短语。公司经常被鼓励将产品匆忙推向市场，以后再解决问题。2016 年，三星匆忙发布了他们的新手机 Galaxy Note 7，他们想击败苹果 iPhone 7 的发布。
Here's a clip from a news report about what happened next. It shows a Galaxy Note 7 apparently smoking, yeah, on fire, it would appear, at a fast food restaurant. A one-store employee, as you can see there, actually used her oven mittens to grab the device. That is not a good thing when one is trying to sell those devices to consumers. What happened to the Apple Samsung race, Sarah? So Samsung had seen that they might have an opportunity. Apple iPhone 7 was going to be coming out that year, and everyone had heard, oh, it's going to be kind of a dull update.
这是接下来发生的事情的新闻报道片段。它显示了一部 Galaxy Note 7 显然在一家快餐店冒烟，是的，着火了。正如你所看到的，一名商店员工实际上用她的烤箱手套抓住了设备。当一个人试图向消费者销售这些设备时，这可不是一件好事。苹果与三星的竞争发生了什么，Sarah？所以三星看到他们可能有一个机会。苹果 iPhone 7 那年要出来，每个人都听说，“哦，这只是一个平淡的更新。”
And Samsung thought this could be a great opportunity to deliver their new splashy product with the Galaxy Note 7. And so they were rushing. to this deadline. However, as we heard in that clip, things did not go well. In their rush, they had some fatal flaws to those batteries. And this was creating all kinds of issues worldwide. And I think most ominously on airplanes, that the devices were overheating. And there was serious fear that this could cause a fire on a plane that would be really catastrophic. And so people were afraid to travel with their devices. There were warnings that came out. It was not good. I mean, I understand
三星认为这可能是一个绝佳的机会，可以用 Galaxy Note 7 推出他们的新产品。所以他们匆忙赶在这个截止日期前。然而，正如我们在片段中听到的那样，事情进展得并不顺利。在匆忙中，他们的电池存在一些致命缺陷。这在世界各地造成了各种各样的问题。我认为最不祥的是在飞机上，设备过热。人们非常担心这可能会导致飞机上发生灾难性的火灾。所以人们害怕带着他们的设备旅行。出现了警告。情况很不妙。我的意思是，我明白
that Samsung eventually had to issue a recall. You know, regulators started banning the phone from various locations. This is not what you want when you're trying to sell a device to consumers. This is not what you want. And I was actually a Samsung owner at the time. And I remember like, oh, no, should I still be having this Samsung? I hadn't upgraded. It led to some serious loss of confidence. in the brand. And so instead of doing the thing of actually capturing this new market by releasing before Apple, they actually were losing customers and losing profits because of that rush. In a world where we are encouraged to fail fast and make overnight recoveries from illness, injury and setbacks, patients can seem like a lost art. When we come back, the psychology of
三星最终不得不发布召回。你知道，监管机构开始在各个地方禁止这款手机。当你试图向消费者销售设备时，这不是你想要的。这不是你想要的。我当时实际上是三星的用户。我记得当时想：“哦，不，我应该继续用这款三星吗？”我没有升级。这导致了对该品牌信心的严重丧失。所以，他们没有通过在苹果之前发布来占领这个新市场，反而因为那种匆忙而失去了客户和利润。在一个我们被鼓励快速失败并从疾病、伤害和挫折中一夜之间恢复的世界里，耐心似乎是一门失传的艺术。当我们回来时，我们将探讨耐心的心理学
patients and techniques to master the art of waiting. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. As a rule, human beings are not inclined toward patients. It's hard to sit quietly in traffic, to deal with a small screaming child in the seat behind you on a plane, to go through a global pandemic where many sources of avocation and entertainment are cut off. At Baylor University, Sarah Schnittker studies the psychology of patients.
以及掌握等待艺术的技巧。你正在收听 Hidden Brain。我是 Shankar Vedantam。这是 Hidden Brain。我是 Shankar Vedantam。作为一种规则，人类并不倾向于耐心。在交通堵塞中安静地坐着、在飞机上应对身后座位上尖叫的小孩、经历一场全球大流行病，许多娱乐来源都被切断，这些都很难。在贝勒大学，Sarah Schnitker 研究耐心的心理学。
Sarah, let's go back to the height of the COVID pandemic. The world was scrambling to find answers to so many questions, including how to treat this rapidly spreading virus. In our fear and in our panic and our desire to get this behind us as quickly as possible, people reached for all manner of outlandish interventions. Here's one news clip that described the moment. The Poison Center is again warning you. Drinking bleach will not prevent catching COVID-19.
Sarah，让我们回到新冠疫情的高峰期。世界正在争先恐后地寻找许多问题的答案，包括如何治疗这种迅速传播的病毒。在我们的恐惧、恐慌以及尽快摆脱它的渴望中，人们尝试了各种各样的古怪干预措施。这是一个描述当时情况的新闻片段。“毒物中心再次警告你。喝漂白剂不能预防感染 COVID-19。”
Center says 46 North Texans drank bleach since the start of August. Sarah, you say that our brains are wired for certainty. What do you mean by this? Yes, human beings want to have answers. We want to have a predictable world where we know when I do X, I get Y. And so we really struggle in situations like the global pandemic when we don't know what's going on. We don't know what to do. And you see people resorting to really dangerous behaviors like drinking bleach because someone told them this is a way to fix it, said it with certainty. And so we rush forward toward that certainty, even though it might actually harm us. And in some ways, when you see a story like this, you know, with a compassionate lens,
“中心称自 8 月初以来，有 46 名北德克萨斯人喝了漂白剂。”Sarah，你说我们的大脑是为确定性而设计的。你这是什么意思？是的，人类想要得到答案。我们想要一个可预测的世界，在那里我们知道当我做 X 时，我会得到 Y。所以我们在像全球大流行病这样的情况下真的很难受，因为我们不知道发生了什么。我们不知道该做什么。你看到人们诉诸像喝漂白剂这样非常危险的行为，因为有人告诉他们这是一种解决办法，而且说得非常肯定。所以我们冲向那种确定性，即使它实际上可能会伤害我们。在某种程度上，当你用同情的眼光看待这样的故事时，
the people who are doing this are doing this because they're afraid. They're doing this because they're worried. They're doing this because they're scared. They don't know what's going to happen and they're trying to protect themselves. Exactly. And I think this is not just kind of a minor fear. It's a global pandemic. And I'm afraid I'm going to die or my loved ones are going to die.
做这些事的人是因为他们害怕。他们这样做是因为他们担心。他们这样做是因为他们害怕。他们不知道会发生什么，他们正试图保护自己。正是如此。我认为这不仅仅是一种轻微的恐惧。这是一场全球大流行病。我害怕我会死，或者我爱的人会死。
And our minds just latch on to something that sounds certain and take action. And that feels better and helps reduce. that uncertainty. I'm wondering if you can talk a moment about why our brains despise uncertainty as much as they do, Sarah. What is the, what is the origin for this, do you think? Well, if you think about kind of our hunter-gatherer ancestors, uncertainty often means a threat that when things are certain, even if there's something
我们的大脑只是抓住了一些听起来确定的东西并采取行动。这感觉更好，有助于减少那种不确定性。我想请你谈谈为什么我们的大脑像它们表现的那样厌恶不确定性，Sarah。你认为这的起源是什么？嗯，如果你想想我们的狩猎采集祖先，不确定性通常意味着威胁。当事情确定时，即使有坏事发生，你至少知道会发生什么以及该做什么。但当事情不确定时，这对人们来说是一种非常厌恶的状态。我们不仅要为威胁做准备，而且我们不知道解决方案是什么。这真的很艰难。在那种不确定性中坚持下去需要付出很大的努力。而且这感觉真的不好。我听说你小时候有过一个时刻，当时你必须决定是否要投资篮球。在某种程度上，这是你与不确定性共处能力的一个例子。告诉我那个故事。你小时候是什么样的，你的篮球故事是什么？我长得很高，长得很快。所以到 12 岁时，我就达到了现在的身高，
bad happening, you know at least what to expect and what to do. But when things are uncertain, it's just such an aversy. state for people. And we have to not only prepare for threat, but we don't know what the solution is. And it really is tough. It takes a lot of effort to persist in that uncertainty. And it just doesn't feel good. I understand that you had a moment when you were a kid, when you had to decide whether to invest in basketball. And in some ways, this was an example of your capacity. to sit with uncertainty. Tell me that story. What were you like as a kid and what was your basketball story? I grew up very tall, very quickly. So by the age 12, I was at my current height,
也就是 5 英尺 11 英寸（约 1.8 米），这对于美国的女性来说相当高。所以当我年轻时，每个人都告诉我：“哦，你一定很擅长运动，你一定是个运动员，你一定要打篮球或排球。”所以当我在四年级加入篮球队时，我无法满足这些期望，我其实并没有那么厉害。我是新手。训练很辛苦。我最后在每一场比赛中都哭了。我知道。这太令人难过了。我记得我母亲在大学里打过篮球，她只是说：“什么？为什么我的女儿搞不定这个？她怎么了？”
which is 5 foot 11, which is quite tall for a woman in the United States. So everyone when I was young was telling me, oh, you must be so great at sports, you must be an athlete, you must play basketball or volleyball. And so when I joined the basketball team in fourth grade, I could not meet these expectations that I wasn't actually that great. I was new to it. The work arts were hard. I ended up crying at every single game we had. I know. It was so sad. And I remember my mother who played basketball in college was just like, what? Why can't my daughter? figure this out. What's wrong with her?
在四年级赛季结束时，我说：“你知道吗？我不擅长运动。”这感觉更安全、更确定、更稳妥，而不是说：“哦，也许我坚持几年，试一试。也许我真的可以很棒。我只是需要更多的练习。”而且，你知道，这是那种事情之一。当我上大学时，我开始锻炼，
At the end of that fourth grade season, I said, you know what? I'm not athletic. That felt much safer and more certain and secure rather than saying, oh, maybe I stick with this for a couple years and try it out. And maybe I actually can be good. I just need more practice. And, you know, it's kind of one of those things. When I got to college, I started working out.
仅仅是因为我的朋友们在锻炼。我实际上意识到，我不擅长这个。我实际上可以变得有点运动能力，强壮，并且擅长与运动相关的事情。所以这是你回顾过去会说：“哦，也许我错过了团队运动带来的所有好处，尤其是对女性运动员而言。”仅仅因为它没有很快到来，而且我害怕也许我无法变得优秀。所以我们谈到了感受不确定性是多么令人厌恶，等待是多么痛苦。你能谈谈无聊在驱动缺乏耐心方面的作用吗，Sarah？是的，尤其是在美国，但我认为在世界各地的许多文化中，我们真的讨厌无聊。
just because my friends were. And I actually realized, I'm not bad at this. I can actually be somewhat athletic and strong and good at things related to sports. And so it's one of those things you look back on and say, oh, maybe I missed out from all the benefits of kind of a team sport that we see for female athletes in particular. Just because it didn't come quickly and I was afraid maybe I couldn't be good. So we've talked about how aversive it is to feel uncertainty, how miserable it can feel to wait. Can you talk about the role of boredom in driving impatient, Sarah? Yes, especially in the United States, but I think in plenty of cultures around the world, we really hate to be bored.
我只是想到我自己小时候，以及现在我自己的孩子在公路旅行时。总是不断的：“我们到了吗？我们到了吗？”就像，你五分钟前才问过我。不，我们还没到。我们只是，我们讨厌无聊。那种无聊的一部分也是，我希望这种情况有所不同。然而我被困在其中。而且不确定它何时会结束。这就是为什么孩子们总是问“我们到了吗？”但我们只是被困在其中。我们之前谈到了 RG3，那位在遭受一系列严重伤害后被匆忙送回赛场的橄榄球运动员。你说运动员经常被劝阻不要请假康复，因为我们想让他们尽快回来。我明白这在奥运会体操运动员西蒙·拜尔斯（Simone Biles）身上也发生了。
I just think of myself as a child and now my own child when you go on a road trip. It's just the constant, are we there yet? are we there yet? Like, you asked me five minutes ago. No, we are not there. We just, we hate to be bored. And part of that boredom, too, is that I want this situation to be different. And yet I'm stuck in it. And it's uncertain when it will end. That's why kids are constantly asking, are we there yet? But we're just stuck in it. We talked earlier about RG3, the football player who was rushed back to the sport after, a set of serious injuries. You say that athletes are often discouraged from taking time off to heal because we want them back quickly. And I understand this played out with the Olympic gymnast, Simone Biles.
所以西蒙·拜尔斯，她在东京奥运会上，发现自己在做扭转动作时，失去了在空中的那种平衡感，于是决定不完成比赛，要休息一下，照顾自己的心理健康。她退出了全能比赛和几个单项决赛，并说：“我必须优先考虑我的幸福。我害怕我会伤害自己。我觉得不安全。我要停止。”并退后了一步。当时人们不喜欢这样。有些人为她鼓掌，但其他人说她让队友失望了。皮尔斯·摩根（Pierce Morgan），我记得他说她让她的队友、她的粉丝失望了，
So Simone Biles, she had been at the Olympics in Tokyo and was finding herself on her twists and turns, losing kind of that sense of equilibrium in the air, and decided that she was not going to finish the competition, was going to take a break, take care of her mental health. She withdrew from the all-around and several finals and said, I've got to prioritize my well-being. I'm afraid I'm going to injure myself. I don't feel safe. I'm stopping. And took that step back. People did not like this at the time. Some people plotted her, but others said she was letting down her teammates. Pierce Morgan, I remember said she's letting down her teammates, her fans,
甚至让她的国家失望了，她怎么敢这样做？她应该坚持下去，拥有像 RG3 那样的毅力故事。但我们实际上看到的是，西蒙·拜尔斯花光了她需要的所有时间，并在 2024 年回到巴黎，在下一届奥运会上表现得非常出色。成为了有史以来获得奖牌最多的奥运体操运动员。所以你看到她实际上能够保持耐心并等待。而不是急于过早回到比赛，而是真正倾听自己的声音，优先考虑她的身体和心灵，
and even her country that, how dare she do this? And she should have pushed through and had that story of grit like RG3. But what we actually see is that Simone Biles took all the time she needed and comes back to Paris in 2024 and absolutely killed it at the next Olympic. became really the most decorated Olympic gymnast ever. So you see that she was able to actually be patient and wait. And instead of pushing to come back to competition too early, really listened to herself and prioritized her body and her mind
以及它所需要的，而不是盲目向前冲。你知道，我记得当她退出东京奥运会时，因为她当时确实和她的队友在东京。东京，她被选中了，她代表国家。我认为在一些评论员中有一种感觉，认为她很自私，她占据了国家队的一个名额，现在却退出了，事实上，剥夺了别人参加奥运会的机会。当然，还有一种关于西蒙·拜尔斯因为不顾一切地表现自己而是一个自私的人的陈词滥调。但当然，从长远来看，这不仅对西蒙·拜尔斯来说是正确的决定。这对体操运动，尤其是对美国来说，都是正确的决定。是的，她需要那段时间。而且，我的意思是，她在 2024 年晚些时候完全统治了赛场。所以我认为这在我们文化中是一种短视的观点。
and what it needed instead of pushing forward. You know, I recall when she withdrew from the Tokyo Olympics because she actually was with her teammates in Tokyo. Tokyo, and she had been selected, she was representing the country. And there was a sense, I think, among some commentators, that she was being selfish, that she had taken a spot on the national team and now was pulling out and, in fact, had deprived somebody else of the opportunity of competing in the Olympics. And of course, there was this trope of Simone Biles as a selfish person for not putting herself out there, no matter the cost. But of course, in the long run, it was not just the right decision for Simone Biles. It was the right decision for, you know, Jim gymnastics in general and certainly for the United States in particular. Yes, she needed that time. And, I mean, she just dominated later in 2024. And so I think it's a short-sighted perspective in general in our culture.
与其说事情需要时间，我们必须耐心，我们想要即时的结果。我的意思是，我真的很惊讶西蒙·拜尔斯有力量不屈服于那种压力。我觉得她所做的一切令人难以置信地勇敢和耐心。我很好奇，Sarah，关于耐心的潜在局限性。在他著名的《伯明翰监狱来信》中，马丁·路德·金牧师表达了他对一次又一次听到“等待”这个词的沮丧，当涉及到民权时。在他就此主题发表的另一场演讲中，他实际上为缺乏耐心的美德辩护。
Instead of saying things take time and we have to be patient, we want instant results. I mean, I'm truly amazed that Simone Biles had the strength to not cave into that pressure. I just thought it was incredibly courageous and patient what she did. I'm curious, Sarah, about the potential limits of patience. In his famous letter from Birmingham jail, the Reverend Martin Luther King, Jr., expressed his frustration with hearing the word, wait, time and time again, when it came to civil rights. In another speech he made on the subject, he actually makes a case for the virtues of impatience.
这是他的话。“我们也来到了这个神圣的地方，提醒美国‘现在’的强烈紧迫性。现在不是从事冷静的奢侈，也不是服用渐进主义镇静剂的时候。”耐心总是美德吗，Sarah？我想我们可能会说，有德行的耐心，好的耐心，总是一种美德。但有一种被称为“过度耐心”的恶习。所以你可以鲁莽行事，
Here he is. We have also come to. this hallowed spot to remind America of the fierce urgency of now. This is no time to engage in the luxury of cooling off or to take the tranquilizing drug of gradualism. Is patience always a virtue, Sarah? I think what we might say is that virtuous patience, good patience, is always a virtue. But there is a vice of what might be called too much patience. So you can be reckless and move forward
带着暴力和鲁莽冲向你的目标，我们通常认为这是缺乏耐心。但你也可以沦为被动、不作为或等待太久的牺牲品。因此，要真正做好耐心，我们必须找到那个真正的“甜蜜点”，即鲁莽与被动之间的黄金中庸之道。所以你看到马丁·路德·金在这场演讲中呼吁：“不，我们不应该再等待了。我们要求权利和平等。”而马丁·路德·金对于耐心来说是一个非常有趣的例子，因为实践公民不服从需要极大的耐心。然而他知道耐心有其局限性，仅仅等待是无法让你走向一个公正和美好的社会的。
with violence and recklessness to your goal, which we often think about as impatience. But you can also fall prey to passivity or in action or in waiting too long. And so to truly be doing patience well, we have to find that real sweet spot, that golden mean between recklessness and passivity. And so you see that MLK is calling out in this speech that, no, we should not be waiting any longer. We demand rights and equality. And MLK is just a really interesting example for patients because it takes immense patience to practice civil disobedience. And yet he knew that patients had its limits and that just waiting around. is not going to get you there towards a just and good society.
所以你看到了人们在日常生活中以及在这些历史事件中必须解决的耐心与行动之间的这种真正的张力。我们如何判断我们何时处于耐心的那个甜蜜点，即我们没有等待太多，但也没有鲁莽行事？你知道，我们在研究中展示的一件事是，一个很好的指标是我们应该看到我们既表现出勇气又表现出耐心。如果你只是在练习耐心，而没有看到勇气的实例，你可能会变得太被动。所以真的，与其仅仅考虑耐心本身，并将其作为你应该尝试做的唯一事情，不如也思考一下：我是否勇敢？即使我可能害怕或感到受到威胁，我是否仍在追求目标？平衡这两者似乎确实有助于确保你不会变得过于耐心和被动。当然，我们在马丁·路德·金的生活中确实看到了这一点。我们看到了丰富的耐心，但也看到了丰富的
And so you see this real tension of patience and action that people have to work out in their daily lives and in these historic events as well. How do we tell when we are at that sweet spot of patients where we're not waiting too much, but we're not being reckless either? You know, one of the things that we've shown in our research is that a great indicator is that we should see that we're acting both with courage and patience. If you're only practicing patience and you don't see instances of courage, you might be coming too passive. So really, instead of thinking about patience just by itself and as the only thing you should be trying to do, also thinking about am I being. courageous? And am I pursuing things even when I might be afraid or feel under threat? And balancing those two really seems to help to ensure that you're not becoming too patient and passive. And of course, we see that certainly in MLK's life. We see abundant patients, but also abundant
勇气。正是如此。我们在一项研究中追踪了参与者四周，观察他们正在追求的目标，并询问他们每个目标中使用了多少耐心和多少勇气。我们发现，当人们像马丁·路德·金一样既有耐心又有勇气时，他们没有表现出被动或鲁莽。但当他们只有其中之一而没有另一个时，那就是你看到他们开始不能很好地追求目标，要么变得被动，要么变得鲁莽。所以这两者结合在一起确实是关键。当我们回来时，我们将探讨我们所有人如何学习变得更有耐心，以及为什么我们应该这样做。你正在收听 Hidden Brain。我是 Shankar Vedantam。
courage. Exactly. We, in one of our studies, we tracked participants over four weeks and we're looking at the goals they were pursuing and asked them about how much patience they were using in each goal and how much courage. And what we found is that when people had both patience and courage like MLK, they did not show passivity or recklessness. But when they had one and not the other, that's when you see them starting not to pursue their goals really well and either becoming passive or reckless. So those two together are really key. When we come back how we can all learn to be more patient and why we should. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
这是 Hidden Brain。我是 Shankar Vedantam。你对今天的节目有什么疑问吗？也许你是一个以极其耐心著称的人。是什么帮助你保持冷静？你是否曾经失去耐心并为此付出了巨大的代价？如果你有一个愿意与 Hidden Brain 听众分享的个人故事，或者对本集有疑问或评论，请找一个非常安静的房间，
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Do you have questions about today's episode? Maybe you're someone who's known as exceptionally patient. What helps you to keep your cool? Have you ever lost your patience and paid a huge price for it? If you have a personal story you would be willing to share with a Hidden Brain audience or a question or comment about this episode, please find a very quiet room
在你的手机上录制一段语音备忘录。两三分钟就足够了。将文件通过电子邮件发送给我们：Feedback@Hiddenbrain.org。使用主题行“patience”。那个电子邮件地址再次是 Feedback@Hiddenbrain.org。在一个以即时满足为荣的世界里，很容易相信耐心是被动的，是某种涉及牺牲和咬牙切齿的事情。
and record a voice memo on your phone. Two or three minutes is plenty. Email the file to us at Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, patience. That email address again is Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. In a world that thrives on instant gratification, it's easy to believe that patience is passive, something that involves sacrifice and clenched,
在贝勒大学，心理学家 Sarah Schnitker 挑战了这个想法。她说，有办法学习耐心的艺术，并使其不那么痛苦。Sarah，你说有三种耐心。你称第一种为“人际耐心”？是的。第一种类型确实是关于对他人的耐心。对你的伴侣、配偶、孩子、同事，以及排在你前面那个似乎找不到硬币来找零的人保持耐心，因为他们为什么要用现金支付，对吧？这些人都是我们生活中需要我们耐心对待的人。Sarah，你是否发现这在你的生活中是真实的，即当你对人际关系保持耐心时，它们实际上会发生转变，变得与你最初想象的完全不同？
teeth. At Baylor University, psychologist Sarah Schnitzker challenges this idea. She says there are ways to learn the art of patients and to make it less painful. Sarah, you say that there are three types of patients. You call the first interpersonal patients? Yes. The first type is really about being patient with other people. Being patient with your relationship partners, with your spouse, your children, your coworkers with the person in front of you in line who can't seem to find the coins to make change because why are they paying in cash, right? This is all the people in our lives who require patience from us. Have you found that to be true in your life, Sarah, that when you have been patient with the relationships, in fact, they transform and become quite different than what you might
是的，我有。而且，你知道，有很多事情会破坏关系，有很多关于他人的事情会让我们烦恼。但随着年龄的增长，我学会了：“你知道吗？也许这个朋友和我现在不在同一个频道上。让我们保持联系。我可能会尝试和他们交谈。”但即使我们不能解决那个具体的冲突，我们也可以回过头来，当你过早地放弃一段新友谊甚至旧友谊时，确实会失去一些东西。而继续对他人的耐心允许深厚关系的丰富性真正成为你生活的一部分。这确实需要大量的耐心和等待。所以我们谈到了人际耐心，
I've imagined at first? Yes, I have. And, you know, there's lots of things that can be disruptive to a relationship and things that annoy us about others. But as I got older, I've learned, like, you know what? Maybe this friend and I aren't on the same page right now. Let's still keep in touch. I might try to talk to them. But even if we can't resolve that specific conflict, we can come back around and that there's something really lost when you give up on a new friendship or even an old one when the person's having a hard time too soon. And that continuing just to be patient with others allows for the richness of deep relationships to really be a part of your life. And it just takes a lot of patience and waiting. So we've talked about interpersonal patients,
但还有在处理工作和生活中的挫折时所涉及的耐心。你能谈谈这个挑战在你个人生活中的作用吗，Sarah？我听说在研究生院的第三年，你患上了一种神秘的疾病。这种疾病的症状是什么？那是一段非常艰难的时光。有一天半夜我开始呕吐，接下来的几个月里我一直处于慢性呕吐状态。后来，在我得到诊断后，我发现我患有一种叫做“周期性呕吐综合征”的疾病，
but there is also the patients involved in dealing with setbacks at work and in life. Can you talk about the role of this challenge in your own life, Sarah? I understand that in the third year of grad school, you became very sick with a mysterious illness. What were the symptoms of this illness? It was a really rough time. I started throwing up one night in the middle of the night, and I proceeded to kind of had chronic vomiting for months. On end, I came to find out later, after I got a diagnosis, I have what's called cyclic vomiting
这是一种相当罕见的疾病。它有点像腹部偏头痛，所以它在大脑中，类似于偏头痛，但不是头痛，我只是开始呕吐。这真的、真的很难。我花了六个月才找到诊断结果。而且，我当时正在研究耐心，然后遇到了这种生活困难，我不得不真正实践我的耐心，并处理这种现在将伴随我一生的慢性疾病。很明显，这不是会消失的东西。这是我必须学会管理的东西。Sarah，我想知道是否有时候你感到非常沮丧，以至于你想放弃，
syndrome, which is a pretty rare disorder. It's kind of like abdominal migraines, so it's in the brain, similar to migraines, but instead of getting a headache, I just would start throwing up. And it was really, really hard. It took me six months to find out a diagnosis. And it was, I was studying patients and then given this life hardship where I had to actually practice my patients and deal with this chronic illness now for my entire life. It became apparent that this is not something that would go away. It was something that I'd have to learn to manage. I'm wondering, Sarah, if there were times when you felt so frustrated that you wanted to give up,
但也感到有点虚伪，因为你正在研究耐心？我确实有这种感觉。但后来还有其他时候，我也发现我对耐心的研究鼓励我花身体需要的时间。我想我当时在学习：“你知道吗？坚持到底并不总是答案。”我实际上会为自己制定一些小规则，比如：“好吧，如果你感到恶心或不舒服，也许去躺下 20 分钟。”看看那种休息和练习正念，或者花点时间，而不是仅仅试图在工作和写作上坚持到底，花点时间回来，对自己稍微
but also felt somewhat hypocritical because you were studying patients. So I definitely felt that. But then there were other times when I also found that my research on patients encouraged me to take the time my body needed. I think I was learning, you know what? Pushing through is not always the answer. And I would actually make little rules for myself of like, okay, if you feel nauseous or are feeling ill, maybe go lay down for 20 minutes. see if that rest and kind of practicing mindfulness or kind of taking time instead of just trying to push through on my work and write, taking the time and coming back and being a little bit
温柔一点，我发现当我这样做时，我在一个月的时间里会更成功，实际上能完成我的工作。所以尝试学习，而不是像 RG3 那样，总是向前冲。我不关心我的身体。我的恶心不重要。我只是要向前冲。这会导致病得太重，以至于我不得不因输液和脱水而住院。所以只是学习西蒙·拜尔斯的教训，倾听我自己的心理健康，倾听我自己的身体健康，优先考虑这些，因为没有我的身体和心灵处于良好的状态，我就无法实现我的其他目标。所以这是一个在生命早期学习到的非常有用的教训，因为我认为我们许多人直到生命后期才学到这一点。
more gentle with myself, I found when I did that, I would be much more successful across the course of a month and actually getting my work done. And so trying to learn instead of being like RG3, with just always pushing forward. I don't care about my body. My nausea doesn't matter. I'm just going to push forward. It would lead to, like, getting so sick that I would have to be hospitalized for fluids and dehydration. So just learning the lesson of Simone Biles of listening to my own mental health, listening to my own physical health, prioritizing those because without my body and my mine in a good place, I couldn't achieve my other goals. And so it was a really useful lesson to learn earlier in life because I think a lot of us don't learn that till later in life.
对自己更温柔一些，我发现当我这样做时，我在一个月的时间里会取得更大的成功，并且能真正完成我的工作。所以，试着去学习，而不是像RG3那样，总是只顾着向前冲。我不关心我的身体，我的恶心感不重要，我只是要向前冲。这会导致我病得非常严重，以至于不得不住院输液和治疗脱水。所以，学习西蒙·拜尔斯的教训，倾听我自己的心理健康，倾听我自己的身体健康，并优先考虑这些，因为如果我的身体和思想不在一个好的状态，我就无法实现我的其他目标。所以，在人生的早期学到这一课是非常有用的，因为我认为我们很多人直到人生的后期才学到这一点。
So besides the challenges that come with our interactions with other people and the challenges that come with these life hardships, there's also the impatience we feel with daily hassles. Now, these don't rise to the level of crisis and catastrophe, but they're still a pain, right, Sarah? I think for a lot of people, when they hear the term patience, they think of being stuck in traffic and stuck in line and what it is, the six months of life, you'll probably stand in line. Like, this is a huge amount of our time. You know, when we practice our patients in these daily habits. Not only doesn't improve that moment, but I also like to think of it as good practice for the bigger life hardships and for our relationships, that the daily hassles might be a nice lower stakes game
除了与他人互动带来的挑战以及生活困境带来的挑战之外，我们对日常琐事的急躁也是一种挑战。这些琐事虽然还没上升到危机和灾难的程度，但确实让人心烦，对吧，莎拉？我想对很多人来说，当他们听到“耐心”这个词时，会想到堵车或排队，而你一生中可能会有六个月的时间都在排队。这占用了我们大量的时间。你知道，当我们练习在这些日常习惯中保持耐心时，不仅能改善当下的心情，我还喜欢把它看作是应对更大生活困境和人际关系的良好练习，日常琐事可能是一个很好的低风险游戏，
to practice patients so that you're ready when you have that illness come up or your child frustrates you in a new way, that you're prepared for those things that might actually be more monumental. I want to go over some of your ideas on how we can build our patients. You say that one way to do this is that when we're feeling impatient, we should stop and reflect on the experience. Now, I think most people want to do exactly the opposite. They don't want to focus on the fact that they're feeling impatient. In fact, they want to get rid of that feeling as quickly as possible. What's the point of dwelling on it, Sarah? Yes, I think it's somewhat counterintuitive, right? We often think of patients like, don't be upset, don't be upset. But we actually find that does not work.
用来练习耐心，这样当你遇到疾病或孩子以新的方式让你沮丧时，你就能为那些可能更重大的事情做好准备。我想回顾一下你关于如何培养耐心的想法。你说过，其中一种方法是，当我们感到急躁时，应该停下来反思这种体验。但我认为大多数人恰恰想做相反的事情。他们不想关注自己感到急躁这一事实。事实上，他们想尽快摆脱这种感觉。莎拉，纠结于这种感觉有什么意义呢？是的，我认为这有点违反直觉，对吧？我们通常认为耐心就是“别生气，别生气”。但我们实际上发现这并不奏效。
And people who are a patient don't actually try to suppress their feelings. Instead, they acknowledge them. And that it's okay to take that moment and say, oh, I'm really frustrated with this person in the workplace who is asking me the same question for the 15th time this week or my partner who is making that funny noise that they always make or my child who's throwing a temper tantrum, right? We actually stop and pause and say, oh, this is what I'm feeling. And just let that feeling be there for a moment. That actually removes some of the power of that feeling. And what you also see is if you can almost try to observe that feeling as a third person,
而有耐心的人实际上并不会试图压抑自己的情绪。相反，他们会承认这些情绪。花点时间对自己说，哦，我真的很沮丧，因为工作中的某个人这周第15次问我同样的问题，或者我的伴侣又发出了他们总是发出的那种奇怪的声音，或者我的孩子正在发脾气，这没关系，对吧？我们实际上停下来，暂停一下，说，哦，这就是我的感受。让这种感觉存在一会儿。这实际上会消除这种感觉的一些力量。你还会发现，如果你能试着像第三者一样观察这种感觉，
instead of just feeling it to say, okay, this is what I'm. feeling. I can understand why. That really is the first step to actually being patient. You also talk about the value of something you call re-appraisal. What is re-appraisal, Sarah? Yeah, so re-appraisal is really just this trick of learning to think about a situation differently. So one common reappraisal strategy is benefit finding. So what is the good thing that I can notice in this scenario? And I know for myself sometimes it's just, oh, great. this is an opportunity to practice my patience waiting in this line. Reappraisal could also include thinking about it from someone else's perspective. So why is this three-year-old screaming on the ground
而不是仅仅去感受它，对自己说，好吧，这就是我的感受。我能理解为什么。这确实是真正做到耐心的第一步。你还谈到了你所说的“重估”的价值。莎拉，什么是重估？是的，重估其实就是学会以不同方式看待情况的技巧。一种常见的重估策略是寻找益处。那么，在这个场景中我能注意到什么好的方面呢？我知道对我自己来说，有时只是想，哦，太好了，这是一个在排队时练习耐心的机会。重估也可以包括从别人的角度思考。那么，为什么这个三岁的孩子在地上尖叫
and kicking? Oh, because they don't have the words or the capacities to tell me what they want. And so this is all they've got and I'm going to feel for them and how they're feeling. And so that reappraisal is just shown across many, many studies, just to be a highly effective way of regulating and helping yourself become more patient. The researcher Kate Sweeney ran a study that looked at how people spent their time during the COVID-19 pandemic. She found that some people were better able to deal with their impatience than others. Can you describe for me what the study found? Yes. What Kate and her colleagues found is that when people were able to immerse themselves in activity,
并踢腿呢？哦，因为他们没有词汇或能力来告诉我他们想要什么。所以这就是他们所能做的，我会同情他们以及他们的感受。许多研究表明，重估是一种调节情绪并帮助自己变得更有耐心的极其有效的方法。研究员凯特·斯威尼进行了一项研究，观察人们在新冠疫情期间是如何度过时间的。她发现有些人比其他人更能处理自己的急躁情绪。你能为我描述一下这项研究的发现吗？是的。凯特和她的同事们发现，当人们能够沉浸在活动中，
and experience what we call flow, that state really helped people to cope well with COVID-19 and all the stressors of the pandemic in China, in particular, during the most intense lockdowns. And so engaging in these flow experiences really help people across time, not just in the moment, but even later when the researchers followed up with them, people who were able to do that were able to be whether it was cooking homemade meals or playing video games even, which we often think of as a negative thing, they found that that can actually induce a flow state. And this was important in that time of really heightened uncertainty. You know, I find sometimes when I'm waiting in line or waiting on hold, I'll pull out my phone and I'll start playing a game of chess.
并体验我们所说的“心流”时，这种状态确实帮助人们很好地应对了新冠疫情以及疫情期间的所有压力源，特别是在中国最严格的封锁期间。因此，参与这些心流体验确实在很长一段时间内帮助了人们，不仅是在当下，即使是后来研究人员对他们进行回访时，那些能够做到这一点的人，无论是做家常饭菜还是玩电子游戏——我们通常认为这是负面的事情——他们发现这实际上可以诱发心流状态。这在那种高度不确定的时期非常重要。你知道，我发现有时在排队或等待电话接通时，我会拿出手机开始下一盘棋。
And within about five or six minutes, I'm so absorbed in the game that when someone finally comes on the phone, I'm like, Why are you interrupting my game? This is far more important than anything I need to talk to you about. Exactly. How dare you have come back so quickly. Yes, I feel the same way. I love to do my writing when I travel. And so it makes that weight in the airport or on the plane just so much faster when I'm like,
五六分钟内，我就完全沉浸在游戏中，以至于当有人终于接通电话时，我会想，你为什么要打断我的游戏？这比我需要和你谈论的任何事情都重要得多。完全正确。你怎么敢这么快就回来。是的，我有同感。我喜欢在旅行时写作。所以当我写作时，机场或飞机上的等待时间过得快多了，以至于我常想，
oh, no, the flight's almost over. I'm a lot longer. Yes, it's a good strategy. We've talked previously on the show, Sarah, about how purpose can give us patience, when it comes to achieving difficult goals. When we know why we are doing something, it becomes easier to bear the setbacks along the way. Talk about the role of purpose in helping us deal with our impatience.
哦，不，航班快结束了。我还需要更多时间。是的，这是一个很好的策略。莎拉，我们之前在节目中讨论过，当实现困难目标时，目标感如何赋予我们耐心。当我们知道为什么要去做某事时，就更容易承受过程中的挫折。谈谈目标感在帮助我们应对急躁方面的作用吧。
It can really motivate us to do better when it comes to patience, when we have a reason for that waiting and for that suffering, that we need a higher order purpose. Why? Why do I continue to suffer in this way? Why should I wait for this thing patiently? When you have that big why, it becomes much easier to practice the how, to actually practice your reappraisal, to practice your naming of the emotion, to get into that flow state. And what we find is that when that purpose is bigger than yourself, it's not just about, me and my pleasure and my positive emotions. Instead, it's something bigger than me. We find in our research that when people have that, they're actually able to be more patient and they actually grow more in patience over time. You ran a study involving Muslim adolescents during the month
当我们有理由去等待和忍受痛苦时，它确实能激励我们更好地保持耐心，我们需要一个更高层次的目标。为什么？我为什么要这样受苦？我为什么要耐心地等待这件事？当你有了那个宏大的“为什么”，练习“如何做”就变得容易多了，比如练习重估，练习命名情绪，进入心流状态。我们发现，当那个目标比你自己更宏大时，它不仅仅是关于“我”和我的快乐以及我的积极情绪。相反，它是比我更伟大的东西。我们的研究发现，当人们拥有这种目标时，他们实际上能够更有耐心，并且随着时间的推移，他们的耐心会增长得更多。你进行了一项涉及穆斯林青少年的研究，是在
of Ramadan. What were these adolescents doing during Ramadan? And what did you find, Sarah? Yes. So Ramadan in Islam actually is called the month of patience. And so during the month of Ramadan, devout Muslims will dry fast from sunrise to sunset. So that means no food or drink, not even water across all of daylight. And this is an incredibly challenging time. But it's also a time of great spirituality. And that, the Islamic community, you see there are all kinds of special rituals and prayers and meals to break the fast or to begin it. And so what we found in our research is that when teenagers were engaged in this Ramadan sacred time, that they actually grew in their patience. And then what was really cool is that a month after Ramadan was over, so back to just kind of normal daily life, they actually sustained some gains in patience. So they were still more patient than before Ramadan had began. So what we interpret is going on here is that they are doing this
斋月期间。这些青少年在斋月期间做了什么？莎拉，你发现了什么？是的。伊斯兰教中的斋月实际上被称为“耐心之月”。在斋月期间，虔诚的穆斯林会从日出到日落进行干斋。这意味着在整个白天不吃不喝，甚至不喝水。这是一个极具挑战性的时期。但这也是一个充满灵性的时期。在伊斯兰社区，你会看到各种特殊的仪式、祈祷和开斋或封斋的餐食。我们在研究中发现，当青少年参与到斋月这个神圣的时期时，他们的耐心确实增长了。更酷的是，在斋月结束一个月后，也就是回到正常的日常生活时，他们实际上保持了一些耐心的增长。所以他们仍然比斋月开始前更有耐心。我们对此的解读是，他们正在进行
really difficult training in patience. And it feels like suffering in the moment. And you really want to be able to get that drink and having to wait for that sun to set is difficult. So when they practice their patience, but do it for a bigger reason to bring glory to Allah and to be a part of their community and do this together with others, it really seems to be a powerful intervention that I'm not doing this for myself, for my physical fitness. I'm doing this because this is what good Muslims do. And we are doing this for the sake of this higher power. And that is an incredibly potent experience. And our data show that it indeed has these benefits for patients long term. I understand that this work has been echoed by other research you did that looked at young adults who were training for marathons.
这种非常困难的耐心训练。在当下，这感觉就像受苦。你真的很想喝水，而不得不等待太阳落山是很困难的。所以当他们练习耐心，但为了一个更宏大的理由——为了荣耀真主，为了成为社区的一部分并与他人共同完成——这似乎确实是一种强大的干预措施。我不是为了自己，为了身体健康而做这件事。我这样做是因为这是好穆斯林所做的。我们是为了这个更高的力量而做这件事。这是一种极其强有力的体验。我们的数据显示，它确实对长期的耐心有这些好处。我知道这项工作得到了你所做的另一项研究的呼应，该研究观察了正在为马拉松训练的年轻人。
Yes. We also looked at adolescents and young adults who were running half or full marathons with a philanthropic training team. And what we found is that they didn't necessarily grow in patience if they were just doing the training for health and fitness reasons. The philanthropic purpose of the training team was to raise money for clean water efforts in about eight African countries when they were running for the sake of helping those other people or running to grow spiritually to get closer to God. when they ran for those motives that were bigger than themselves, that's when you see them also grow in their patients through this training activity. I'm wondering, Sarah, if we can take a moment and talk about what scientists like yourself are finding about the costs of impatience. Yes.
是的。我们还观察了参加慈善训练团队进行半程或全程马拉松的青少年和年轻人。我们发现，如果他们仅仅是为了健康和健身原因进行训练，他们的耐心并不一定会增长。训练团队的慈善目的是为大约八个非洲国家的清洁水项目筹集资金，当他们为了帮助那些人而奔跑，或者为了精神成长、为了更接近上帝而奔跑时，当他们为了那些比自身更宏大的动机而奔跑时，你就会看到他们通过这种训练活动增长了耐心。莎拉，我想请你花点时间谈谈像你这样的科学家在急躁的代价方面发现了什么。是的。
We see that impatience leads to not just irritability or negative emotions, but higher risk of heart problems, difficulty, handling stressors. Stress starts to actually become anxiety. We see it can lead to a lack of self-control. We also see that impatience is associated with loneliness. So I think this makes a lot of sense. If you are unable to be patient with other people and you are impatient toward them, that's going to be a strain on the relationship. It's going to be harder to have those deep connections. Then we also see one of the most robust associations we found in my research is that inpatients is associated with greater depressive symptoms. And conversely, that patients helps to ameliorate depression
我们看到，急躁不仅会导致易怒或负面情绪，还会增加心脏问题的风险，以及处理压力源的困难。压力实际上开始变成焦虑。我们看到它会导致缺乏自控力。我们还看到急躁与孤独有关。所以我认为这很有道理。如果你不能对他人保持耐心，并且对他们感到急躁，那将对关系造成压力。建立深层联系会变得更加困难。然后我们还看到，在我的研究中发现的最稳健的关联之一是，急躁与更严重的抑郁症状有关。反之，耐心有助于改善抑郁
symptoms over time. There's one form of patients that I think we have not discussed, Sarah, and that is patients with ourselves. We've talked about how we need to be patient with others, with the illnesses that afflict us, with hardships, with the hassles of daily life. But as we look at ourselves, and especially if we look at ourselves honestly and critically, we will find flaws and we will find limitations. And that is a source of frustration as well. Can you talk a moment about the value of being patient with ourselves? Patience with ourselves is quite critical.
症状。莎拉，我认为我们还没有讨论过一种耐心，那就是对自己保持耐心。我们谈到了我们需要对他人、对折磨我们的疾病、对困难、对日常生活的琐事保持耐心。但当我们审视自己时，特别是如果我们诚实且批判性地审视自己时，我们会发现缺陷，也会发现局限性。这也是挫折的来源。你能谈谈对自己保持耐心的价值吗？对自己保持耐心至关重要。
Oftentimes, people have experience. expectations for themselves that might even be higher than the expectations they have for others. And so patience with ourselves is partly recognizing our own limitations as humans, that we are not superhuman, that we are just human beings and flawed like everyone else. Just like we have to have self-compassion, we also have to have patience with ourselves and realize, is that growth and whether that's growth in kind of our character, our morals, our abilities, our relationships that we're not going to be where we want to be right now and that it's a long game. There was a famous quote.
通常，人们对自己有期望，这些期望甚至可能比他们对他人的期望还要高。因此，对自己保持耐心在某种程度上是承认我们作为人类的局限性，我们不是超人，我们只是普通人，和其他人一样有缺陷。就像我们必须有自我同情一样，我们也必须对自己保持耐心，并意识到，无论是性格、道德、能力还是人际关系的成长，我们现在都不会达到我们想要的位置，这是一场持久战。有一句名言。
I think it was Stanislaw, Lex, said you have to have a lot of patience to become more patient. And, you know, someone might listen to a session. like this and say, okay, I'm going to become more patient and really try to do it quickly and then become discouraged and just give up and say, oh, I'm just an impatient person. I can't be good at this. So I think learning to have patience is a slow go, and it's going to take a lot to practice. And I don't think anyone gets it done very quickly. Sarah Schnitker is a psychologist at Baylor University. Sarah, thank you so much for joining me
我想是斯坦尼斯瓦夫·莱克说的，你必须有很大的耐心才能变得更有耐心。而且，你知道，有人可能会听这样的节目，然后说，好吧，我要变得更有耐心，并真的试图快速做到这一点，然后感到气馁，直接放弃，说，哦，我只是一个急躁的人。我做不好这个。所以我认为学习保持耐心是一个缓慢的过程，需要大量的练习。我不认为任何人能很快完成。莎拉·施尼特克是贝勒大学的心理学家。莎拉，非常感谢你今天加入
today on Hidden Brain. Thank you for having me. Do you have a story to share with the Hidden Brain audience on the subject of patience? Maybe you're someone who's known as exceptionally patient. What helps you to keep your cool? Have you ever lost your patience and paid a huge price for it? If you have a personal story you would be willing to share with a hidden brain audience or a question or comment about this episode, please find a very quiet room and record
Hidden Brain节目。谢谢你的邀请。你有什么关于耐心主题的故事想与Hidden Brain的听众分享吗？也许你是一个以极其耐心而闻名的人。是什么帮助你保持冷静的？你是否曾经失去耐心并为此付出了巨大的代价？如果你有一个愿意与Hidden Brain听众分享的个人故事，或者关于这一集的问题或评论，请找一个非常安静的房间并录制
a voice memo on your phone. two or three minutes is plenty. Email the file to us at feedback at hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, patience. That email address again is feedback at hiddenbrain.org. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
手机上的语音备忘录。两三分钟就足够了。将文件通过电子邮件发送给我们，地址是feedback@hiddenbrain.org。使用主题行“patience”。再次重复该电子邮件地址，feedback@hiddenbrain.org。你正在收听的是Hidden Brain。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是Hidden Brain。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
In his final semester in college, a young Harrison Ford took an acting class. A self-described loner, he used acting to get over his shyness. In the process, he became obsessed with learning how to tell a story. Harrison Ford pursued acting as a career and secured a weekly contract with a Hollywood studio as a small-time TV actor. It was a decent start, but he craved more. He wanted to be a star. At the same time, the struggling actor had a wife and two young sons. He had purchased a rundown home in the Hollywood Hills and spent his free time teaching himself to fix it up.
在大学的最后一个学期，年轻的哈里森·福特上了一门表演课。他自称是一个孤独的人，他利用表演来克服害羞。在这个过程中，他沉迷于学习如何讲故事。哈里森·福特将表演作为职业，并与一家好莱坞制片厂签订了一份每周合同，成为一名小有名气的电视演员。这是一个不错的开始，但他渴望更多。他想成为明星。与此同时，这位挣扎中的演员有一位妻子和两个年幼的儿子。他在好莱坞山买了一栋破旧的房子，并利用业余时间自学修理它。
Eventually, to pay the bills, he decided to quit his TV contract and become a full-time carpenter. But Harrison Ford never quite gave up the dream of landing a major film role. One day, he ran into an old acquaintance as he was working on a carpentry project for the director of Francis Ford Coppola. The acquaintance, a young director named George Lucas. The director asked the wannabe movie star to read lines with actors auditioning for his new film. It was a little project called Star Wars. The rest, as they say, is history. Harrison Ford landed a starring role
最终，为了支付账单，他决定辞去电视合同，成为一名全职木匠。但哈里森·福特从未完全放弃获得重要电影角色的梦想。有一天，当他为导演弗朗西斯·福特·科波拉做木工项目时，他遇到了一个老熟人。那个熟人是一位名叫乔治·卢卡斯的年轻导演。导演请这位想成为电影明星的人与为他的新电影试镜的演员对台词。那是一个名为《星球大战》的小项目。正如他们所说，剩下的就是历史了。哈里森·福特获得了一个主演角色，
in one of the most significant movie franchises of the 20th century. He hasn't done many carpentry gigs since then. We hear success stories like this all the time. The actress waiting tables, the musician ghostwriting songs, the writer toiling at an advertising agency. They labor in obscurity until one fine day, they catch a break and become famous. There's something irresistible about these stories.
在20世纪最重要的电影系列之一中。从那以后，他没做过多少木工活。我们一直听到这样的成功故事。等待上菜的女演员，代写歌曲的音乐家，在广告公司苦干的作家。他们在默默无闻中劳作，直到有一天，他们抓住了机会并成名。这些故事中有一种不可抗拒的东西。
They give us hope that we too will catch a break, that we too will get to pursue meaningful work that we love. At Babson College, Jennifer Toasty Kara studies the benefits and the costs of having a calling. She joined us for a recent episode. It was titled Passion vs. Paycheck. Today, we welcome Jennifer back to answer listener questions in our popular segment, your questions answered. Jennifer Toasty-Karris, welcome back to Hidden Brain.
它们给了我们希望，希望我们也能抓住机会，希望我们也能追求我们所热爱且有意义的工作。在巴布森学院，詹妮弗·托斯蒂-卡里斯研究了拥有使命感的好处和代价。她参加了我们最近的一集节目。那一集的标题是“激情与薪水”。今天，我们欢迎詹妮弗回来，在我们的热门环节“你的问题已解答”中回答听众的问题。詹妮弗·托斯蒂-卡里斯，欢迎回到Hidden Brain。
Thank you so much, Shankar. I am beyond thrilled to be back. Jen, your graduate school advisor, Amy Reznesski, came up with a framework to help us understand how people think about their relationships to work. She suggested that people think of their work in one of three ways, as a job, as a career, or as a calling. Talk about these three categories
非常感谢，尚卡尔。我非常激动能回来。珍，你的研究生导师艾米·雷兹内斯基提出了一个框架，帮助我们理解人们如何看待他们与工作的关系。她建议人们以三种方式之一看待他们的工作：作为一份工作、作为一种职业或作为一种使命。谈谈这三个类别，
and what Amy found when she asked people to talk about their work? So just to break them down, a job orientation is when you work primarily for the extrinsic rewards from that work. So work is a means to an end, and it's typically a financial end. So working primarily for the money it provides, and maybe then you pursue a passion outside of work, that's a job. A career is when you similarly work as a means to an end, but this time it is the means to advancing within either an organizational hierarchy, picture climbing the typical career ladder, or gaining respect and centrality in an occupational community. So picture like, you know, coders who like to gain the respect of others,
以及艾米在请人们谈论他们的工作时发现了什么？所以，简单分解一下，工作导向是指你主要为了工作带来的外在回报而工作。所以工作是达到目的的一种手段，通常是经济目的。所以主要是为了它提供的金钱而工作，也许你在工作之外追求激情，这就是一份工作。职业是指你同样把工作作为达到目的的一种手段，但这一次它是为了在组织等级制度中晋升，想象一下攀登典型的职业阶梯，或者在职业社区中获得尊重和核心地位。所以想象一下，比如，喜欢获得他人尊重的程序员，
like, whoa, you wrote that code. That would be a career orientation toward the work. Then finally, we have a calling. And when work is a calling, it is not a means to an but a meaningful end in and of itself. It is a source of fulfillment, of passion. You often feel consumed by the work. And often, but not always, you would say your work makes the world a better place. It's just a major, major part of who you are, pretty much inseparable from life compared to the other two. One of the things that I find intriguing is that Amy found that people who fell into
比如，哇，你写了那段代码。那将是一种对工作的职业导向。最后，我们有使命。当工作是一种使命时，它不是达到目的的手段，而是本身就是一个有意义的目的。它是成就感、激情的源泉。你经常感到被工作所消耗。而且通常，但不总是，你会说你的工作让世界变得更美好。它只是你身份中一个非常、非常重要的部分，与生活几乎不可分割，相比前两者。我发现有趣的事情之一是，艾米发现那些属于
all three categories, regardless of what their jobs were. So you could ask the same questions of three surgeons or three accountants or three journalists and find that the same job did not hold the same meaning for different people. What do we make from that, Jen? Yeah, absolutely. So the meaning of the work in this framework is really in the eye of the beholder. So just as you said, you can have two people, same job, same organization, you know, same occupation, and one feels it's a job, and one feels it's a calling. And that means I could be working right alongside you or even with you on a work team. And we feel very differently about the meaning that that work has within our lives. I think another interesting thing that Amy found is that this distribution of jobs, careers,
所有三个类别的人，无论他们的工作是什么。所以你可以问三位外科医生、三位会计师或三位记者同样的问题，发现同一份工作对不同的人并没有同样的意义。珍，我们对此有何看法？是的，绝对。所以在这个框架中，工作的意义确实在观察者的眼中。正如你所说，你可以有两个人，同一份工作，同一个组织，你知道，同一个职业，一个人觉得这是一份工作，另一个人觉得这是一种使命。这意味着我可以和你并肩工作，甚至和你在一个工作团队中。我们对这份工作在我们生活中所具有的意义有着非常不同的感受。我认为艾米发现的另一件有趣的事情是，这种工作、职业、
and callings, which was about a third, a third and a third across people in a given population, really held regardless of the type of work. So it was as common in professionals as it was in, for example, administrative assistance. So this notion that, oh, you know, everybody who works or more people who work as a, you know, lower level in the organization, feel their work as a job, and people with, you know, very immersive or important occupations might feel their work as a calling, that didn't really hold either. So really, I think what we make of this is that it's less about what you're doing and even maybe less about you and this interaction of you and the job that creates the meeting.
和使命的分布，在给定人群中大约各占三分之一，无论工作类型如何，确实都成立。所以它在专业人士中和在行政助理中一样普遍。所以这种观念，哦，你知道，每一个工作的人，或者更多在组织中处于较低级别的人，觉得他们的工作是一份工作，而拥有非常沉浸式或重要职业的人可能会觉得他们的工作是一种使命，这也不太成立。所以真的，我认为我们对此的理解是，这与其说关于你在做什么，甚至可能与其说关于你，不如说关于你与工作的这种互动创造了意义。
We discussed this during our last conversation, but can you remind us of some of the benefits of having passion in your work or finding a calling? Yeah. A lot of the benefits of calling are really really. driven by an extra engagement in and motivation to do that work. So these are the employees who go above and beyond. They put in the effort. They, you know, show up to work even, you know, they don't miss as much work. The work they do is potentially very good and very high quality. They're very diligent about it. They just, they care about doing that work a lot. And then,
我们在上次谈话中讨论过这个问题，但你能提醒我们拥有工作激情或找到使命的一些好处吗？是的。使命感的许多好处确实是由对工作的额外投入和动力驱动的。所以这些是超越自我的员工。他们付出了努力。他们，你知道，即使在工作中也表现出色，他们不会错过太多工作。他们所做的工作可能非常好，质量很高。他们对此非常勤奋。他们只是，他们非常关心做好那份工作。然后，
Similarly, there are benefits for the worker themselves. So research, including my own, has found that experiencing a calling toward your work spills over to benefit your life as a whole. So we might say it gives your life meaning, it gives you a purpose. That's really good for us in general. It can lead us to feel our lives are good, thinking about life as a whole and not just life at work. One of the things that I really enjoyed about our last conversation is that you not only talked about the benefits of having a calling, but some of the potential downsides of having a calling.
同样，对工人自己也有好处。所以包括我自己在内的研究发现，体验到对工作的使命感会溢出，从而使你的整个生活受益。所以我们可能会说它赋予了你生活意义，它给了你一个目标。这对我们总体来说真的很好。它能引导我们感到我们的生活是美好的，思考整个生活，而不仅仅是工作中的生活。我非常喜欢我们上次谈话的一点是，你不仅谈到了拥有使命感的好处，还谈到了拥有使命感的一些潜在弊端。
What are some of them? Yeah, so this is sort of that other side of the coin that as good as callings can be. There's also this side of it where that extra passion, that extra effort, that willingness to go above and beyond, can turn into an over-commitment where you're almost doing too much. You're putting in too much of yourself and then not leaving room for other areas of your life and potentially opening yourself up to exploitation. So along with my co-author on my book, Is Your Work Worth It, Christopher Michelson, we've started exploring in some more recent work this notion that maybe callings are best experienced not as an extreme high or an extreme low, but really in this sort of middle space.
它们是什么？是的，所以这就像硬币的另一面，使命感可以很好。但也有这样的一面，那种额外的激情，额外的努力，那种超越自我的意愿，可能会变成一种过度承诺，你几乎做得太多了。你投入了太多的自己，然后没有为生活的其他领域留下空间，并可能使自己面临被剥削的风险。所以，我和我的书《你的工作值得吗？》的合著者克里斯托弗·米歇尔森一起，在最近的一些工作中开始探索这样一种观念，即使命感最好不要作为一种极端的快乐或极端的痛苦来体验，而是真正处于这种中间空间。
And when we push to those extremes is when we see some of the downsides, either we're not at all committed or we're overcommitted. Let's turn now to questions from the audience. We heard from a listener named Elizabeth who says she and her husband have very different expectations about what they will get out of work. I grew up in a family focused on each of us kids finding our calling. Fast forward to me as an adult, and I've tried all different kinds of helping professions in my 15 years post-college in the work field, and I'm still trying to figure it out.
当我们推向那些极端时，我们就会看到一些弊端，要么我们根本没有承诺，要么我们过度承诺了。现在让我们转向听众的问题。我们收到了一位名叫伊丽莎白的听众的来信，她说她和她的丈夫对他们能从工作中得到什么有非常不同的期望。我在一个专注于我们每个孩子寻找自己使命的家庭中长大。快进到我成年后，在我大学毕业后的15年工作生涯中，我尝试了各种各样的帮助性职业，我仍然在试图弄清楚它。
And my husband is tired of me complaining about work not being the perfect fit for me. My husband grew up in a blue-collar community, and to him, work is work. You just find something that pays the bills, and the idea of a calling was kind of a foreign concept. And so this has been this tension that I've been examining more and more
而我的丈夫厌倦了我抱怨工作对我来说不是完美的契合。我的丈夫在一个蓝领社区长大，对他来说，工作就是工作。你只是找一份能支付账单的工作，而使命的概念对他来说是一种陌生的概念。所以这一直是我一直在审视的紧张关系，
as I continue to seek and not find my calling. In some ways, Jen, what Elizabeth is saying is that people who think of their work as a job and people who think of their work as a calling might look at one another with mutual incomprehension. So Elizabeth, thank you for sharing that perspective. That is actually such a common occurrence for couples to have what we might call incongruent work orientations. One feels it's a job, the other feels it's a calling, that it can make it hard to know what do I really want in work and that this is, and you almost question just as Elizabeth is doing, you know, is this really what I want and is, you know, what sort of what am I looking for and what do I value?
随着我继续寻找却找不到我的使命。在某种程度上，珍，伊丽莎白所说的是，把工作视为一份工作的人和把工作视为一种使命的人可能会以相互无法理解的眼光看待对方。所以伊丽莎白，谢谢你分享那个观点。夫妻之间出现我们可能称之为“不一致的工作导向”的情况确实非常普遍。一个人觉得这是一份工作，另一个人觉得这是一种使命，这会让人很难知道我在工作中真正想要什么，而且这几乎让你质疑，就像伊丽莎白正在做的那样，你知道，这真的是我想要的吗，我到底在寻找什么，我重视什么？
And greater incongruence not only leads to, you know, uncertainty and a longer job search, but ultimately a lower probability of reemployment. The more incongruence of your work orientation with your partner, the less satisfied you are with your job, there's an interesting caveat to that unless you are the one with the higher calling, and then you are more satisfied with your job. So it's almost this like social comparison. Now, Elizabeth's example, I think, speaks more to the seeker nature of this, but it suggests that if she were, to be employed and feel that that work was her calling, she might actually experience more satisfaction as a function of her husband viewing his work as just a job. Is there any research that explains why it is different people might look at work as a job
而且更大的不一致不仅会导致，你知道，不确定性和更长的求职时间，而且最终会导致更低的再就业概率。你与伴侣的工作导向越不一致，你对工作的满意度就越低，这有一个有趣的警告，除非你是那个拥有更高使命感的人，那么你对工作的满意度就会更高。所以这几乎就像是一种社会比较。现在，伊丽莎白的例子，我认为更多地说明了这种寻求者的本质，但它表明，如果她被雇用并觉得那份工作是她的使命，她实际上可能会因为她的丈夫将他的工作视为一份工作而体验到更多的满意度。有没有研究解释为什么不同的人可能会把工作视为一份工作
versus look at it as a calling? Does it have to do with our upbringing and what we've been taught as children? Yeah. So there, I mean, definitely needs to be significantly more work done on this, but there are a few studies, and I want to point to one by Catherine Dekees and Wayne Baker, that looked at exactly what happens in adolescence through socialization with parents. So no surprise, we start thinking about work early in our lives through interaction with, you know, significant others, but a huge influence on us is our parents. What our parents, you know, feel about their work, the meaning they make of their work influences us. And it does, in some pretty interesting ways. So kids develop stronger calling orientations when both parents
而不是把它视为一种使命？这与我们的成长经历以及我们作为孩子所受的教育有关吗？是的。所以，我的意思是，绝对需要在这方面做更多的工作，但有几项研究，我想指出凯瑟琳·德基斯和韦恩·贝克的其中一项，它观察了在青春期通过与父母的社会化过程中到底发生了什么。所以不出所料，我们通过与重要他人的互动，在生命早期就开始思考工作，但对我们影响巨大的是我们的父母。我们的父母对他们的工作有什么感觉，他们对工作的意义的理解影响了我们。而且确实，以一些非常有趣的方式。所以当父母双方
possess strong calling orientations. Other work has looked at the journey toward when we feel our work is a calling and finds that just having role models and influences, seeing people kind of model the way of experiencing their work as a calling can be inspiring to us. Now, of course, the other side of that is pressure, but it can be inspiring to us. And so parents might be our earliest form of those role models. There are many professions that people enter into as a calling, but once in the profession, they find that there are significant portions of that profession that involve boring activities or mundane activities.
拥有强烈的使命感时，孩子会发展出更强的使命感导向。其他工作观察了我们何时觉得工作是一种使命的旅程，发现仅仅拥有榜样和影响，看到人们以某种方式模拟将工作体验为使命的方式，就能激励我们。当然，另一面是压力，但它能激励我们。所以父母可能是我们最早的那些榜样形式。人们进入许多职业是作为一种使命，但一旦进入该职业，他们发现该职业中有很大一部分涉及无聊的活动或平凡的活动。
I'm thinking about someone who decides to become a firefighter, and so they have this very glamorous vision of running into burning buildings. and rescuing people. But if you're a firefighter, much of your time actually is just spent sitting around, waiting for someone to call, and a lot of the job might actually be quite boring. I'm wondering what happens, Jen, when people who expect that their work is going to be unendingly interesting and glamorous and counter the boring parts that come with every profession. Yeah, I try to really give my students a realistic preview of that. Like, even the most meaningful work does not feel meaningful all the time. So I think just even have,
我想到一个决定成为消防员的人，所以他们对冲进燃烧的建筑物并营救人们有一个非常迷人的愿景。但如果你是一名消防员，你的大部分时间实际上只是坐在那里，等待有人呼叫，而且很多工作实际上可能相当无聊。珍，我想知道当那些期望他们的工作将是无休止地有趣和迷人，并抵消每种职业带来的无聊部分的人会发生什么。是的，我尽量给我的学生一个现实的预览。就像，即使是最有意义的工作也不会一直感觉有意义。所以我认为仅仅有，
this realistic preview of like, you're a firefighter, but it's not all glamour and excitement and how it seems on TV shows and movies. Now, of course, when we're talking about firefighters, I do think about work by Mike Pratt and colleagues that looked specifically at callings and firefighters and found that a lot of what really drives them is the camaraderie with the other firefighters. So it's funny, like, I could be bored sitting around the firehouse. And but I'm with my buddies, and that's really, that's who I show up for. And even in the glamorous role of putting out a five alarm blaze, I'm thinking about them and keeping them safe, and it sort of translates over. But I want to entertain your idea of, you know, I have lofty goals,
这种现实的预览，比如，你是一名消防员，但它并不像电视节目和电影中那样全是魅力和兴奋。当然，当我们谈论消防员时，我确实想到了迈克·普拉特及其同事的研究，他们专门观察了使命感和消防员，发现真正驱动他们的很多东西是与其他消防员的友情。所以这很有趣，比如，我可能在消防站坐着很无聊。但我和我的伙伴们在一起，这才是真正我为之出现的原因。即使在扑灭五级火灾的迷人角色中，我也在想着他们并确保他们的安全，这在某种程度上转化了过来。但我想要考虑你的想法，你知道，我有崇高的目标，
and then I get in my job, and it is just, you know, there is not a lot to remind me about that bigger picture. Sometimes what I would recommend is just trying to see the way that the work, though boring, is still helping. And that could be helping you. It could be helping, you know, you and your pursuits or your family or what happens outside of work. It could be helping society. Just you don't feel you're as, you know, personally responsible for it. But I think it's sort of this, there needs to be some kind of a balance between having a realistic expectation that even the most lovable work is not lovable every single minute of every single day. And also thinking about, you know, how much, there does become a point at which I think if you
然后我进入了我的工作，它只是，你知道，没有太多东西能提醒我那个更大的图景。有时我会建议尝试看看工作的方式，虽然无聊，但仍然有帮助。这可能是在帮助你。它可能是在帮助，你知道，你和你的追求或你的家庭或工作之外发生的事情。它可能是在帮助社会。只是你觉得你没有，你知道，个人对此负责。但我认为这是一种，需要某种平衡，既要有现实的期望，即即使是最可爱的工作也不是每分每秒都可爱。还要考虑，你知道，有多少，确实有一个点，我认为如果你
are unable to sustain a meaningful connection to the work you're actually doing, you do need to listen to that and think about when is it time to change things up. When we come back, how our passions change over time and ways to find a new calling when your old one no longer satisfies you. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Do what you love and you'll never work a day in your life. It's a phrase we've all heard and many of us have internalized the idea that if you experience a deep passion for what you do, your work won't feel like a burden. In fact, the word work itself comes from the ancient Greek term Ergon, which means the outcome of someone who achieves an inner
无法维持与你实际所做工作的有意义的联系，你确实需要倾听这一点，并考虑什么时候是改变的时候了。当我们回来时，我们的激情如何随时间变化，以及当你的旧使命不再满足你时寻找新使命的方法。你正在收听的是Hidden Brain。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是Hidden Brain。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。“做你所爱的事，你一生中就不会工作一天。”这是我们都听过的一句话，我们许多人都内化了这样一种观念：如果你对你所做的事情体验到深沉的激情，你的工作就不会感觉像是一种负担。事实上，“工作”这个词本身来自古希腊词“Ergon”，意思是实现内心的人的结果
desire, a purpose. At Babson College, Jennifer Toasty-Carris studies how we find meaning in our work and the benefits and the costs of pursuing a calling. Jen, one interesting sentiment we heard from listeners is that one's passion for work can evolve over time, perhaps because of the work itself or changing life circumstances. A listener named Christina is in her mid-30s and has been able to make ends meet as a part-time singer in New York City. But she recently decided to take a full-time day job. Things changed for me in the past few years. I just realized that I needed more structure, more stability.
欲望，一个目的。在巴布森学院，詹妮弗·托斯蒂-卡里斯研究我们如何在工作中找到意义，以及追求使命的好处和代价。珍，我们从听众那里听到的一个有趣的观点是，一个人对工作的激情会随着时间的推移而演变，也许是因为工作本身或生活环境的变化。一位名叫克里斯蒂娜的听众三十多岁，一直能够作为纽约市的一名兼职歌手维持生计。但她最近决定找一份全职的白天工作。过去几年里，我的情况发生了变化。我只是意识到我需要更多的结构，更多的稳定性。
And there are other things I want life. Like, I've wanted a cat for a long time. I'd like to travel a little bit more. See my family without having to worry about every single cent I spend on plane tickets to go see them. You know, own a home someday. And those things just wouldn't be possible if I continued on the trajectory I was on. And so starting this new day job has been interesting because rather than making me feel like I've lost something, I feel like I've gained something.
而且生活中还有其他我想要的东西。比如，我一直想要一只猫。我想多旅行一点。看看我的家人，而不必担心我花在机票上去看他们的每一分钱。你知道，有一天拥有一个家。如果我继续我所走的轨迹，这些事情是不可能实现的。所以开始这份新的白天工作很有趣，因为与其让我觉得我失去了什么，我感觉我获得了什么。
What I find striking about Christina's story, Jen, is that she doesn't seem to feel what many others feel. She doesn't feel like she has sold out or traded down or given up on what matters to her. In some way, she has expanded her definition of what matters to her. Yeah, so I love Christina. story, and I think that this is very emblematic that the only way for work to have meaning is not just to feel that work has to be a calling. So work can be meaningful and add, in fact, a lot to one's life if it's a job that fuels our passion or our meaningful life outside of work. And I think Christina's story is an example of this. And we tend to, we venerate callings in our
珍，关于克里斯蒂娜的故事，我发现引人注目的是，她似乎没有感觉到许多其他人所感受到的。她不觉得她已经出卖了自己，或者降级了，或者放弃了对她重要的事情。在某种程度上，她扩大了对她重要的事情的定义。是的，所以我喜欢克里斯蒂娜的故事，我认为这非常有象征意义，即工作有意义的唯一方式不仅仅是觉得工作必须是一种使命。所以工作可以是有意义的，事实上，如果它是一份为我们在工作之外的激情或有意义的生活提供燃料的工作，它确实可以为人的生活增加很多。我认为克里斯蒂娜的故事就是这方面的一个例子。我们倾向于，我们在我们的
society, but they're not the end-all be-all. We talked earlier about the problems that they can cause for people and actually directly for having a more balanced life. And so I think that, you know, a typical life change that might affect how we view our work is partnering, maybe having kids or other dependents and suddenly feeling like the best use of my time is to not only provide for those other people in our lives, but be able to spend time with them. So shifting away from sort of what I always thought I wanted to do in an ideal world where money didn't matter or other things in life didn't matter. And sort of this ideal bumps up against the reality of how we actually want to live our lives. Many of us do struggle when our passion.
社会中崇拜使命感，但它们并不是全部。我们之前谈到了它们可能给人们带来的问题，实际上直接影响了拥有更平衡的生活。所以我认为，你知道，一个可能影响我们如何看待工作的典型生活变化是结伴，也许有了孩子或其他受抚养人，突然觉得我时间的最佳利用不仅是为我们生活中的那些其他人提供，而且能够花时间与他们在一起。所以从某种我一直认为我想在金钱不重要或其他生活中的事情不重要的情况下在理想世界中做的事情中转移出来。这种理想与我们实际想要生活的方式的现实发生了碰撞。我们许多人确实在我们的激情
is no longer within reach. Perhaps we lose a job or we fall out of love with our current one. A listener named Wendy was a federal worker who recently got fired as part of the Trump administration's mass layoffs. Here she is. All of my stuff went into storage yesterday. I'm moving out of my place to go stay with my little sister while I try to figure out a new career.
不再触手可及的时候挣扎。也许我们失去了一份工作，或者我们不再爱我们目前的工作。一位名叫温迪的听众是一名联邦工作人员，最近作为特朗普政府大规模裁员的一部分被解雇了。她在这里。我所有的东西昨天都进了仓库。我正搬出我的住处，去和我妹妹住在一起，同时我试图弄清楚一个新的职业。
But there's a lot of emotional processing that I'll need to do as well. As I come to understand what the loss of this job, this work means for me. What does this process look like for most people, Jen? As I hear Wendy, I'm hearing grief, someone who's dealing with a loss. Absolutely. So I'm so glad and honored to hear Wendy's story. And I think I'm also really holding some very deep sympathy for her
但我也需要进行很多情感上的处理。随着我逐渐理解这份工作、这项事业的失去对我意味着什么。珍，对大多数人来说，这个过程是什么样的？当我听到温迪的故事时，我感受到的是悲伤，是一个正在处理失去的人。当然。所以我非常高兴且荣幸能听到温迪的故事。我想我也对她怀有非常深切的同情。
because these layoffs affected government workers who many of them chose government work, specifically to help in a broader, in a broader way, help our society, help our country. They weren't necessarily thinking about more extrinsic reasons for working. I mean, again, this is a prototypical kind of area we would expect to see some strong callings. And so I think, you know, regardless of your orientation toward your work, losing a job is really hard.
因为这些裁员影响了政府工作人员，他们中的许多人选择政府工作，正是为了以一种更广泛的方式帮助我们的社会，帮助我们的国家。他们不一定是在考虑更外在的工作理由。我的意思是，这再次是一个典型的领域，我们期望看到一些强烈的使命感。所以我想，无论你对工作的态度如何，失去工作确实是非常困难的。
It can lead to everything from just a more fundamental question about, you know, will I be able to put food on the table, maintain my rent, keep my lifestyle, what else will have to change in my life, to these really higher order questions of who am I? What is my identity now that I'm not working? I miss my friends who were part of that workplace. I mean, it's a loss on sort of every level. So I think to equate it to, you know, loss and to have a grieving process, I mean, that is borne out in research on job loss. There is absolutely, if you will, more lost than just the job. There's sort of everything that goes with it and including, and especially for someone for whom the work was a strong calling, this idea that it's part of my identity, it gives
它可能导致各种问题，从更基本的问题，比如，我还能维持生计吗，付得起房租吗，保持我的生活方式吗，我的生活中还有什么需要改变，到这些更高层次的问题，比如我是谁？既然我不工作了，我的身份是什么？我怀念那些作为工作场所一部分的朋友们。我的意思是，这在某种程度上是全方位的损失。所以我认为将其等同于损失并经历一个悲伤的过程，这是有关于失业的研究支持的。绝对不仅仅是失去了工作。还有随之而来的一切，包括，特别是对于那些将工作视为强烈使命感的人来说，这种认为它是自我身份一部分的想法，它赋予了
meaning to my life. So there's really a lot that's lost there. And I think this notion that we can just easily, you know, plug and play and replace that loss becomes even harder the more attached we were to that job. We heard from a journalist named David who's struggling with the state of his industry. He finds himself questioning the stories he was told about his supposed calling. If your original belief in a calling was predicated on something that you subsequently learned was wrong, you start to question whether the work is your calling. So what do you do then?
我生命意义。所以那里确实失去了很多。我认为这种认为我们可以轻易地，你知道，即插即用并取代那种损失的想法，在我们对那份工作越依恋时就变得越困难。我们从一位名叫大卫的记者那里听说，他正在为他所在行业的现状而挣扎。他发现自己开始质疑那些关于他所谓使命感的故事。如果你最初对使命感的信念是基于你后来发现是错误的东西，你就会开始质疑这份工作是否真的是你的使命。那么你该怎么办？
What happens if you realize your work might not be your calling or no longer is your calling? I know that people pivot in life. Can people have multiple callings within their careers and lifespans? In some ways here, Jen, I'm hearing an echo of what Wendy said. David is also saying in some ways that he was given a promise and the promise didn't hold up. And I'm hearing almost a sense that he feels betrayed by the promise not working out. What do you make of this question? Can people, in fact, have multiple callings within one lifetime? Let me start by saying, I think David's story will resonate with a fair number of people. The world is changing so much. Technology is coming online. I mean, all the endless discussions about AI and what will be left of a lot of our jobs once we fully realize sentient AI.
如果你意识到你的工作可能不是你的使命，或者不再是你的使命，会发生什么？我知道人们在生活中会转变。人们在他们的职业生涯和寿命中可以有多种使命吗？在某些方面，珍，我听到了温迪所说的话的回响。大卫也在某种程度上说，他得到过一个承诺，但这个承诺没有兑现。我几乎听到一种他感到被承诺没有实现而背叛的感觉。你如何看待这个问题？人们实际上可以在一生中拥有多种使命吗？让我先说，我认为大卫的故事会引起相当多人的共鸣。世界正在发生巨大的变化。技术正在上线。我的意思是，关于人工智能以及一旦我们完全实现感知人工智能后，我们的许多工作还会剩下什么的无休止讨论。
and I think there's a lot of concern that the callings that we imagined might not be the callings that we're living out. And that's a real concern and I think a real problem. So, you know, beyond journalism or government work, sort of I think a lot of people can can really identify with that. When it comes to multiple callings, there's interesting research by Justinberg, Adam Grant, and Victoria Johnson. And they find that even if we're, we have on the one hand fulfilled one of our callings, we're still very acutely aware that there's something else out there that we're not doing. And that every time we're sort of reminded of that unfulfilled calling, we are really motivated to go seek it out. So absolutely, the notion that
我认为人们非常担心我们想象中的使命可能并不是我们正在实践的使命。这是一个真正的担忧，我认为也是一个真正的问题。所以，你知道，除了新闻业或政府工作，我想很多人真的可以对此感同身受。当谈到多种使命时，贾斯汀伯格、亚当·格兰特和维多利亚·约翰逊有有趣的研究。他们发现，即使我们一方面实现了我们的一个使命，我们仍然非常敏锐地意识到还有其他我们没有做的事情。而且每当我们被提醒那个未实现的使命时，我们真的有动力去寻找它。所以绝对，这种观念
this metaphor of calling is like a romantic partner and there's just one out there for you and you just have to find it. And once you find it, it's smooth sailing. I mean, just the same way that we are unpacking this notion about romantic partners or, you know, life partners, it's a very similar thing for work and for callings. For most of us, there's not just one calling out there and we have to venture to find it, but rather that we can, there can be multiple things that would fulfill us and that I always say when in doubt, just have experiences, try to, you know, learn from trial and error and reflect on what's working and what's not. Because odds are it's out there if you are attentive to it and looking for it. We got a lot of listener questions
这种使命的隐喻就像一个浪漫伴侣，外面只有一个适合你，你只需要找到它。一旦你找到了，就一帆风顺了。我的意思是，就像我们正在剖析关于浪漫伴侣或生活伴侣的这种观念一样，工作和使命也是非常相似的。对于我们大多数人来说，外面不仅仅只有一个使命，我们必须去寻找它，而是说，可以有多种事情能满足我们，我总是说，当有疑问时，去体验，尝试通过试错来学习，并反思什么有效，什么无效。因为如果你关注它并寻找它，很可能它就在那里。我们收到了很多听众的问题
about your research, Jen. It was a really popular topic with our audience. And I think the reason is because, you know, especially in the U.S., our work lives play such a central role in our identities. A listener named Midian called in. She's worked in the film industry for more than 20 years as a makeup effects artist. But recently she became jaded, so she's transitioned into a role that involves teaching and training other makeup artists. But she says it's been a tricky change to navigate. This transition has been so painful, mostly because I am, makeup effects. And what am I without that?
关于你的研究，珍。这对我们的听众来说是一个非常受欢迎的话题。我认为原因在于，你知道，特别是在美国，我们的工作生活在我们的身份中扮演着如此核心的角色。一位名叫米迪安的听众打来电话。她在电影行业工作了20多年，是一名特效化妆师。但最近她变得厌倦了，所以她转型为一个涉及教学和培训其他化妆师的角色。但她说这是一个很难驾驭的改变。这种转变非常痛苦，主要是因为我就是特效化妆。没有了那个，我是谁？
It has been quite a process. And I've had to just like, Gagan, get rid of everything. I'm moving to Albania. I'm going to just let it all go. And the more I let go, the better I'm feeling. I'm wondering, Jen, if you can talk about the link between who we are and what we do for work, because one thing I'm hearing in Midian's question is that for her, her job was not just a calling. Her job was who she was. Yeah, I actually wrote down Midian's quote, I am makeup effects. What am I without that? That's such a powerful way of stating, I think, the emotional experience of callings for many people, that it's not just what I do, it's who I am.
这确实是一个过程。我不得不像加甘一样，摆脱一切。我要搬到阿尔巴尼亚。我要放手一切。我放手得越多，感觉就越好。珍，我想知道你是否能谈谈我们是谁与我们从事的工作之间的联系，因为我在米迪安的问题中听到的一点是，对她来说，她的工作不仅仅是一种使命。她的工作就是她自己。是的，我实际上记下了米迪安的话，我就是特效化妆。没有了那个，我是谁？我认为这是一种非常有力的表达方式，表达了许多人对使命的情感体验，即它不仅仅是我所做的，它就是我是谁。
And I think part of that is it's very American. I think it's a very culturally situated view. But I also think, it's something that is definitional to a strong calling. It's certainly the way I think about it. It is not just the fact that I understand why I'm doing my work in a broader picture, but it really says something about me and my values and then transmits it to others. Often when we measure callings, one of the scale items that we use that we ask people to agree or disagree with is one of the first things that I tell people about myself is what I do for work. And I just think that that really says it all. It's a point of pride. It's a point of identity. And so then, of course, as Midian is saying, to go without it feels especially challenging. We almost can't imagine it. I do wonder, can that
我认为这部分是因为它非常美国化。我认为这是一种非常文化定位的观点。但我也认为，这是强烈使命感的定义性特征。这当然是我思考它的方式。这不仅仅是我理解为什么我在更广阔的图景中做我的工作，它确实说明了关于我和我的价值观，然后将其传递给他人。当我们衡量使命感时，我们使用的量表项目之一，我们要求人们同意或不同意的是，我告诉人们关于我自己的第一件事就是我的工作。我只是认为这说明了一切。这是一种自豪感。这是一种身份认同。所以，当然，正如米迪安所说，没有它感觉特别具有挑战性。我们几乎无法想象。我确实想知道，那能不能
give you the sense that I found it once before. I can find it again. I think that's what I would like to be the optimistic view of this for those who have experienced a calling and then maybe fallen, you know, whether it was taken away from them or they chose something different, fallen out from their calling. I would like to think there's some hope. You know, hearing these notes from listeners really shows me how much of a hunger there is for callings out there. So many people really want to feel inspired by what they're doing. We heard from many listeners wondering about finding a calling in retirement. Has they been research looking specifically at finding a passion later in life, Jen?
给你一种我以前找到过它，我还能再找到它的感觉？我想这就是我希望为那些经历过使命感然后可能跌落的人，你知道，无论是它被夺走了，还是他们选择了不同的东西，脱离了他们的使命，所持有的乐观观点。我愿意相信还有一些希望。你知道，听到这些听众的留言真的让我看到外面对于使命感有多么渴望。很多人真的想从他们正在做的事情中感到受启发。我们从许多听众那里听说，他们想知道在退休后如何找到使命。珍，是否有专门研究在晚年寻找激情的研究？
I mean, there is research on how to think about retirement and actually embracing retirement, sort of not as an end point when life is over. I mean, I think a lot of people view it like that. So I can't imagine what I would do if I wasn't working. And again, this is part of this cultural message. that were often fed that says who you are is what you do. And if you're no longer doing work, you know, do you even have value? But I think that retirement is an opportunity for people to, I think, pursue passions or do meaningful, I mean, work or do meaningful, you know, volunteer activities
我的意思是，有关于如何思考退休以及实际上拥抱退休的研究，某种程度上不是将其视为生命结束的终点。我的意思是，我认为很多人是这样看待它的。所以我无法想象如果我不工作我会做什么。再一次，这是这种文化信息的一部分，我们经常被灌输，说你是谁就是你做什么。如果你不再工作，你知道，你还有价值吗？但我认为退休是人们追求激情或做有意义的工作，或者做有意义的志愿者活动的机会
or hobbies that maybe work got in the way of. So the people that I, you know, and again, this isn't research, but more anecdotal, but the people I know who are happy, in retirement really see the benefits. They're not sort of focusing on the fact that work went away, but they're focusing on the benefits that retirement opens up for them in terms of, wow, I could never hike all the high peaks in my area when I had a day job. I could never learn a new skill that now I, you know, practice every day when I was working. What does retirement open up time and other resources to do that you couldn't do before. So it's really not an ending of anything or sort of an ending of certainly life,
或者爱好，这些可能是工作所阻碍的。所以我认识的人，你知道，再一次，这不是研究，而是更多的轶事，但我认识的在退休后快乐的人，真的看到了好处。他们并没有专注于工作消失的事实，而是专注于退休为他们带来的好处，比如，哇，当我有日常工作时，我从来不能徒步我所在地区的所有高峰。当我在工作时，我从来不能学习一项我现在每天练习的新技能。退休为做你以前做不到的事情打开了时间和资源吗？所以它真的不是任何事情的结束，或者当然不是生命的结束，
but a chance to live in a new and hopefully more meaningful way. When we come back, Jen shares her advice for people still searching for their calling. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. At Babson College, Jennifer Toasty-Carris says finding a calling in work can lead to a range of benefits for our physical and mental health.
而是一个以新的、希望是更有意义的方式生活的机会。当我们回来时，珍将分享她给那些仍在寻找使命的人的建议。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在巴布森学院，詹妮弗·托斯蒂-卡里斯说，在工作中找到使命感可以为我们的身心健康带来一系列好处。
But the pursuit of a calling can also come at a cost. Jen, let's talk a moment about some of those drawbacks. Here's a listener named Catherine who had a question about it. I just turned 40 yesterday. and what I really wanted to do for my birthday was work. I run a company that makes artwork, and it's a luxury brand, and it looks very successful on the outside.
但追求使命感也可能付出代价。珍，让我们谈谈其中的一些弊端。这是一位名叫凯瑟琳的听众，她对此有一个问题。我昨天刚满40岁。我生日那天真正想做的事情就是工作。我经营一家制作艺术品的公司，这是一个奢侈品牌，从外面看非常成功。
But when I was recently featured in the Wall Street Journal, I couldn't even afford more than two copies of the paper. Most weeks, I end up with just a few dollars in my own account, and more than that, the sacrifices you talked about really resonant. The work is exhausting and sometimes even dangerous. I will probably die from the work. I have to get heavy metal blood testing every month and will probably develop silicosis or have already, but it feels meaningful to support artists and create something lasting. Thank you for reminding me that I'm not alone in trying to balance passion with paycheck. So if I'm hearing Catherine, right, Jen, she's really driven and she feels passionately about her work, but she's also struggling economically and sacrificing her health to do what she loves. How can a person think about balancing those competing priorities in their life? So what I think is so telling and powerful about what Catherine's said just now is that, I mean, to me, this is such a prototypical downside of a strong call.
但当我最近被《华尔街日报》报道时，我甚至买不起超过两份报纸。大多数星期，我自己的账户里只剩下几美元，更重要的是，你谈到的牺牲真的引起了共鸣。工作令人筋疲力尽，有时甚至很危险。我可能会因为这份工作而死。我必须每个月进行重金属血液测试，并且可能会患上矽肺病，或者已经患上了，但支持艺术家并创造持久的东西感觉很有意义。谢谢你提醒我，在平衡激情与薪水方面，我并不孤单。所以如果我没听错凯瑟琳的话，珍，她真的很有动力，对她的工作充满热情，但她也在经济上挣扎，并牺牲她的健康来做她热爱的事情。一个人如何考虑平衡生活中这些相互竞争的优先事项？所以我认为凯瑟琳刚才所说的是如此具有说明性和力量，我的意思是，对我来说，这是强烈使命感的典型负面影响。
story in that it's almost like you can't help but not do it. You know it's probably too much. You know that probably it's not great for your health or not great for your relationships, but you just, you've you've got to do it almost at all costs. I mean, to me, this is that strong calling verging on a too strong calling. And so in terms of how to balance this better, I do think, I mean, Catherine seems nothing if not self-aware about the situation. That would be the first step is just are you even sort of aware of the toll that it's taking on you? She seems to be, and then at the same time saying, but she still continues to choose it. I think it's very important to pay attention to if this is a long game and if you are your, you know, psychological health, your physical health,
故事在于，这几乎就像你忍不住不做它。你知道这可能太多了。你知道这可能对你的健康不好，或者对你的人际关系不好，但你只是，你几乎不惜一切代价必须做它。我的意思是，对我来说，这就是那种强烈的使命感趋向于过强的使命感。所以关于如何更好地平衡这一点，我确实认为，我的意思是，凯瑟琳对这种情况非常了解。第一步就是你是否甚至意识到它对你造成的伤害？她似乎意识到了，但同时又说，她仍然继续选择它。我认为非常重要的是要注意这是否是一场持久战，以及如果你是你的，你知道，心理健康，你的身体健康，
your relationships with others who enable your life or keep you grounded are are compromised, but it actually can affect the longevity and sustainability of your ability to do that work. So I think if things get too out of whack, that in and of itself can keep you from doing the work that is so meaningful to you. So if that really is a priority in a big picture, longer term way, are these actions sustain, you know, can I sustain these actions over time? I mean, in some ways, we're talking about callings that are spilling over into obsessions. We talked in our last episode about the very word calling.
你与那些使你的生活成为可能或让你保持脚踏实地的人的关系受到损害，但这实际上会影响你从事该工作的寿命和可持续性。所以我认为如果事情变得太失衡，这本身就会让你无法做那些对你非常有意义的工作。所以如果这在宏观、长期的角度上确实是一个优先事项，这些行动是可持续的吗，你知道，我能随着时间的推移维持这些行动吗？我的意思是，在某些方面，我们谈论的是正在演变成痴迷的使命感。我们在上一集中谈到了使命这个词。
I mean, originally, it started in a religious context. You were called by God. That was what a calling was. God was basically telling you, set down your work and come and do the things that I have set out for you. And you can easily see if, you know, God is actually calling you to do something. you know, maybe you don't have time to have a shower. Maybe you don't have time to meet a friend for a cup of coffee because God's on the other line. So you're absolutely right.
我的意思是，最初它是在宗教背景下产生的。你是被上帝召唤的。这就是“天职”的含义。上帝基本上是在告诉你，放下你的工作，来做我为你安排的事情。你可以很容易地看出，如果上帝真的在召唤你去做某事，也许你没有时间洗澡，也许你没有时间去和朋友喝杯咖啡，因为上帝正在另一条线上和你通话。所以你是绝对正确的。
And in fact, the moralization of callings is something that is happening increasingly. And I think is one of the primary drivers of these effects is the fact, Stuart Bunderson and Jeff Thompson in their study of zookeepers described it as a moral duty. I have to do it. The animals need me. Some beneficiary needs me. It's my drive to do this, but it feels morally significant that if I were to choose something else, that would be a problem. And we see this showing up. So we do see a cultural veneration of callings that it's sort of, we believe it's better to have a calling than a career or a job. Certainly, we sometimes refer to jobs as just a job. and there's increasing evidence that in the workplace callings are venerated, that, for example,
事实上，天职的道德化现象正日益增多。我认为这是产生这些影响的主要驱动力之一，斯图尔特·邦德森（Stuart Bunderson）和杰夫·汤普森（Jeff Thompson）在对动物园管理员的研究中将其描述为一种道德义务。我必须这样做。动物需要我。某些受益者需要我。这是我做这件事的动力，但如果我选择其他事情，那将是一个问题，这在道德上显得意义重大。我们看到这种情况正在出现。因此，我们确实看到了对天职的文化崇拜，即我们认为拥有天职比拥有职业或工作更好。当然，我们有时把工作仅仅称为“一份工作”。而且越来越多的证据表明，在工作场所，天职受到崇拜，例如，
those with stronger callings are perceived to be the better performers, putting in more effort, deserving of more pay and promotions. And interestingly, even when that's not objectively the case, that's the subjective sense we have of them, is that they're the good employees. There's another study about believing that those who are intrinsically motivated by and passionate it for the job are deserving of more help than others. So all of this kind of combines to create this both, I think, pressure to feel like work is a calling and also if you've found it, this moral imperative to just do the work at any cost, that it's that much more important.
那些有更强天职感的人被认为表现更好，投入更多努力，理应获得更多报酬和晋升。有趣的是，即使客观情况并非如此，我们对他们的主观感觉也是他们是好员工。还有另一项研究表明，人们认为那些受内在动力驱动并对工作充满热情的人比其他人更值得帮助。因此，所有这些结合在一起，既创造了一种感觉工作必须是天职的压力，也创造了一种道德上的当务之急，即一旦你找到了它，就必须不惜一切代价去完成这项工作，因为它显得更加重要。
We heard from a number of listeners who pointed out that not everyone has the ability to pursue a calling. Here's a listener who is also named Jen. I listened to your episode about calling, and I think that I would push back against it because many of us don't have the privilege to do something that we would love because we would have no way to pay to live while we did that. So when I graduated college, I had a degree, wanted to work in documentary film, That did not work out, and my degree is pretty worthless, so I had to go back to school and did something extremely practical, which is nursing. And I very much dislike it, but it allows me to pay the mortgage and pay for hobbies. So I think it's actually safe to detach yourself from what you do for
我们从许多听众那里听到，他们指出并非每个人都有能力追求天职。这是一位也叫珍（Jen）的听众。我听了你们关于天职的那一集，我想反驳一下，因为我们许多人没有特权去做我们喜欢的事情，因为我们在做那些事情时无法维持生计。所以当我大学毕业时，我有一个学位，想从事纪录片工作，但这行不通，我的学位几乎毫无价值，所以我不得不回到学校做了一些非常实际的事情，那就是护理。我非常不喜欢它，但它让我能够支付抵押贷款和支付爱好。所以我认为，将自己与工作分离开来实际上是安全的，
work because it can be a pretty sad road and I was depressed for several years because I had been raised thinking that you identify yourself based on your so-called calling because ever since I can remember in the 80s it was what do you want to be when you grow up but what you want to be when you grow up isn't necessarily what you can be when you grow up unless you're independently wealthy or extremely talented or just very very lucky. So we heard early early. So we heard early from Christina Jen, she has chosen to do more practical things because they allow her to do things that she now wants. She wants to travel, spend time with her family, get a cat. We're hearing in some ways a mirror image of that story here. Listener Jen is telling us she made similar
因为那可能是一条相当悲伤的道路，我曾抑郁了好几年，因为我从小就被灌输一种思想，即你应该根据所谓的“天职”来定义自己。因为从我记事起的80年代开始，人们总是问“你长大后想成为什么样的人？”但除非你家境富裕、才华横溢或非常非常幸运，否则你长大后想成为的人并不一定是你能够成为的人。所以我们很早就听到了克里斯蒂娜·珍（Christina Jen）的故事，她选择了做更实际的事情，因为这让她能够做她现在想做的事情。她想旅行，花时间陪伴家人，养一只猫。我们在某种程度上听到了这个故事的镜像。听众珍（Jen）告诉我们，她做了类似的
trade-offs but takes no pleasure in the work that she's doing. I don't hear relief. I hear sadness, regret, maybe even some resentment. Yeah, I think those themes absolutely came out loud and clear in Jen's story. And I really appreciate the honesty. And I think that's absolutely, we ask people to trade off between money and meaning all the time. I think we don't even as a society always question the fact that we do that. So I think that is a tradeoff that a lot of people face. And I think actually to Jen's original point, you know, is it a privilege to do what you love? I think that's absolutely true. I mean, there are so many people, if we think about our world and how many people really don't even have freedom to choose whether to work, what they do for work, how much control and autonomy they have over what their own workday looks like. Absolutely, these are questions of privilege and I don't want to pretend otherwise. I think, first of all, it's important that we think about a society in which no one has to do work. that is truly meaningless or denigrated or what David Graber once referred to as bull-shops jobs
权衡，但从她所做的工作中没有得到任何快乐。我听不到解脱。我听到的是悲伤、遗憾，甚至可能还有一些怨恨。是的，我认为这些主题在珍的故事中表现得非常清晰。我真的很欣赏这种诚实。我认为这绝对是，我们一直要求人们在金钱和意义之间进行权衡。我认为作为一个社会，我们甚至并不总是质疑我们这样做的事实。所以我认为这是很多人面临的权衡。而且我认为，回到珍最初的观点，你知道，做你喜欢的事情是一种特权吗？我认为这绝对是真的。我的意思是，有很多人，如果我们思考我们的世界，有多少人甚至没有自由去选择是否工作，从事什么工作，对自己的工作日有多少控制权和自主权。绝对地，这些都是特权问题，我不想假装不是这样。我认为，首先，我们思考一个没有人必须从事真正毫无意义、被贬低或大卫·格雷伯（David Graber）曾经提到的“狗屁工作”的社会是很重要的，
that, you know, just sort of exist to perpetuate a hierarchy with, you know, no intrinsic value or purpose. So within a subset of the people who do have some choice over what they do for their work, I think the decision to prioritize, well, as Jen says, paying the mortgage and what's safe, I think that's a defensible position. You shouldn't feel less than because you prioritized stability, security, even a certain lifestyle over work that maybe was more lovable or more likable. However, it would be nice if that work didn't make you feel sad or make you feel that you actively dislike it. If you have the privilege to be able to change what you do or who you do it with, is there a way you can, as we call it, job craft, to turn that work of patient care
你知道，这些工作只是为了维持等级制度而存在，没有任何内在价值或目的。因此，在那些对工作有一定选择权的人群中，我认为优先考虑，正如珍所说，支付抵押贷款和追求安全，我认为这是一个站得住脚的立场。你不应该因为优先考虑稳定、安全甚至某种生活方式，而不是那些可能更可爱或更讨人喜欢的工作而感到自卑。然而，如果那份工作不会让你感到悲伤或让你感到积极地讨厌它，那就太好了。如果你有特权能够改变你所做的事情或与谁一起做，有没有办法可以，正如我们所说的，进行“工作重塑”，将那种病人护理的工作
into something that seems, you know, less like a dredgery and more like a source of what you find meaningful about work? And I think this is one of the mechanisms that gets to one person's job being another person's calling. What are you making of the work? And in some regards, what are you doing and who are you doing it with? We heard from one listener who spoke very explicitly about the role of social comparisons in how he is thinking about whether he has a calling. Here's Jesse. I think the idea of work as a calling is one of the most harmful ideologies in our culture today. If you look at the research about job satisfaction, the predictors are pretty straightforward. You should have good relationships with the people that you work with, fair compensation, a sense of appreciation and respect from those above you and those beside you, a positive work-life balance, opportunities for growth.
变成某种看起来，你知道，不那么像苦差事，而更像是你认为工作有意义的来源？我认为这是导致一个人的工作成为另一个人的天职的机制之一。你从工作中得到了什么？在某些方面，你在做什么，你和谁一起做？我们从一位听众那里听到，他非常明确地谈到了社会比较在他思考自己是否拥有天职时的作用。这是杰西（Jesse）。我认为将工作视为天职是当今文化中最有害的意识形态之一。如果你看看关于工作满意度的研究，预测因素非常直接。你应该与一起工作的人有良好的关系，有公平的报酬，有来自上级和同事的赞赏和尊重，有积极的工作与生活平衡，有成长的机会。
And in my life, I have all these things, but I still feel unfulfilled because I compare my job with other people who seem to have that sense of calling. And I crave that. I earned a PhD in research psychology because I found the discipline interesting. And I just, I loved learning. It wasn't a calling, but it was a lot of fun. And the work I do now is based on the skills that learned in my PhD program. It's not really fun or interesting, but it is a really good job. I have all those predictors of job satisfaction, but I don't have that sense of calling. And that one thing seems to undermine all the other positive things in my life. I try to ignore it, but I wonder every day what I should be doing instead of this. That is so powerful, Jen. What do you make of it?
在我的生活中，我拥有所有这些东西，但我仍然感到不满足，因为我把我的工作与那些似乎有天职感的人进行了比较。我渴望那种感觉。我获得了研究心理学的博士学位，因为我发现这门学科很有趣。我只是，我热爱学习。这不是天职，但它很有趣。我现在所做的工作是基于我在博士课程中学到的技能。它并不真的有趣或令人兴奋，但它确实是一份非常好的工作。我拥有所有那些工作满意度的预测因素，但我没有那种天职感。而那一件事似乎破坏了我生活中所有其他积极的事情。我试着忽略它，但我每天都在想我应该做些什么来代替这个。这太震撼了，珍。你怎么看？
Jesse's story is really such a powerful and vivid illustration of the downside of this cultural pressure to find our callings, that anything less really makes us feel like a failure. I mean, if we look at the things that Jesse talked about, he, I mean, he said it very succinctly. It's a really good job. It feels like he would like what he's doing, comes to terms with it, knows why he chose it, sort of went in with eyes wide open. And it's just the fact that he feels that others are more fulfilled or have, you know, this bigger sense of a calling. And he doesn't. That's like the one thing that's standing in the way and the fact that it's sort of swamping all these other things that
杰西的故事确实是一个非常有力且生动的例子，说明了这种寻找天职的文化压力的负面影响，即任何低于此的东西真的让我们觉得自己是个失败者。我的意思是，如果我们看看杰西谈到的事情，他，我的意思是，他非常简洁地说出来了。这是一份非常好的工作。感觉他会喜欢他正在做的事情，接受它，知道他为什么选择它，算是睁大眼睛进来的。只是他觉得别人更满足，或者有，你知道，这种更大的天职感。而他没有。这就像是阻碍他的一件事，事实上它正在淹没所有其他
are really positive for him. I mean, that's powerful. And I think Jesse is really acknowledging this is coming through social comparison and this is coming through cultural pressure and that doesn't make it any easier to dismiss these feelings. These feelings are clearly very real for him. We received a flood of messages from listeners sharing their frustrations over not finding a calling in their professional lives.
对他来说非常积极的事情。我的意思是，这很震撼。而且我认为杰西确实承认这是通过社会比较产生的，这是通过文化压力产生的，但这并不能让这些感受更容易被忽视。这些感受对他来说显然是非常真实的。我们收到了大量听众发来的信息，分享他们在职业生涯中没有找到天职的挫败感。
I'd like to play a few of those messages for you, Jen. I feel that arriving at one's calling is somewhat a fun. of luck in life. I'm 37 and I still don't know what I want to do with my career. When I think about a calling, I don't feel like I've had that experience. I'm wondering what advice you all would give to someone who deeply desires to find that calling in life, but so far for whatever reason has not figured that out.
我想为你播放几条这样的信息，珍。我觉得找到一个人的天职在某种程度上是生活中的一种运气。我37岁了，我仍然不知道我想在职业生涯中做什么。当我想到天职时，我不觉得我有过那种经历。我想知道你们会对那些非常渴望在生活中找到天职，但到目前为止由于某种原因还没有弄清楚的人提出什么建议。
So those were listeners, Dave, Katerina, Alex, and Stacey. I'm wondering about Stacey's last question there, Jen. what are two or three specific steps that people can take if they haven't yet found their calling, but hope to do so? Yeah. So I want to take the pressure off people that it's not a better calling if you knew it from childhood, or it's not a more pure calling if you feel that it's the only one thing you've ever imagined yourself doing. It's a more A to B kind of journey, and it's a little simpler, cleaner than the alternative. But it doesn't make it better or it doesn't. make it any more, more or less a calling. So there are people who have studied the pathways to finding a calling. So Matt Bloom, Amy Colbert, and Jordan Nielsen looked into this. And they found two types of pathways. The one I just described, I know my one true calling and I sort of venture toward it.
所以那些是听众戴夫（Dave）、卡特琳娜（Katerina）、亚历克斯（Alex）和斯泰西（Stacey）。我很好奇斯泰西的最后一个问题，珍。如果人们还没有找到他们的天职，但希望这样做，他们可以采取哪两三个具体的步骤？是的。所以我想减轻人们的压力，如果你从小就知道它，它并不是更好的天职，或者如果你觉得它是你唯一想象过自己做的事情，它也不是更纯粹的天职。这更像是一种从A到B的旅程，它比另一种选择更简单、更清晰。但这并不能让它变得更好，或者让它变得更多或更少地成为一种天职。所以有人研究过寻找天职的途径。马特·布鲁姆（Matt Bloom）、艾米·科尔伯特（Amy Colbert）和乔丹·尼尔森（Jordan Nielsen）对此进行了研究。他们发现了两种类型的途径。我刚才描述的那一种，我知道我唯一真正的天职，我朝着它冒险。
And then this other path called discerning a calling, which is really what I see for your your callers. It's more about having experiences, but not just at random, not just randomly trying things, you know, throw the spaghetti at the wall and see what sticks, but really thoughtfully learning through trial and error. It has to be an iterative, reflective learning process. So you try something, you learn what you liked about it, you learn what you didn't like about it, you try, you know, adjust it accordingly and try again. And that that in and of itself is a pathway toward people ultimately at the end of this feeling like they're in work that was a calling. And also paying attention to, you know, what kind of signals are you
然后是另一种被称为“辨别天职”的路径，这确实是我为你那些听众看到的。这更多的是关于拥有经验，但不仅仅是随机的，不仅仅是随机地尝试事情，你知道，把意大利面扔到墙上看看哪根粘住了，而是通过反复试验进行深思熟虑的学习。它必须是一个迭代的、反思性的学习过程。所以你尝试一些事情，你了解你喜欢它的什么，你了解你不喜欢它的什么，你尝试，你知道，相应地调整它并再次尝试。而这本身就是一条通往人们最终在最后感到他们从事的工作就是天职的途径。同时也要注意，你知道，你从外部得到了什么样的信号？
getting from outside? So are there people who are exemplars and have a sort of career that you might want? What can you learn from them? Talking to them, talking about their journey, talking about how they knew. I mean, really, just talking about callings, getting people's stories and finding inspiration from it and when all else fails, or not even when all else fails, but just let's not forget, there are also resources, you know, I, for the number of times that people have said they took, talk to a coach or they took a class on, you know, how to change careers or how to make a pivot or how to get to meaningful work. I mean, I do think, and humbly as someone who wrote a book about this, I do think reading books, taking courses, talking to a coach, you know, just
所以有没有人是榜样，并且拥有你可能想要的职业？你能从他们身上学到什么？和他们交谈，谈论他们的旅程，谈论他们是如何知道的。我的意思是，真的，只是谈论天职，获取人们的故事并从中找到灵感，当一切都失败时，或者甚至不是当一切都失败时，但让我们不要忘记，还有资源，你知道，我，对于人们说他们咨询了教练或者他们参加了关于，你知道，如何改变职业或如何进行转型或如何获得有意义的工作的课程的次数，我的意思是，我确实认为，作为一个写过关于这个主题的书的人，我谦虚地认为，阅读书籍、参加课程、与教练交谈，你知道，只是
putting some time and attention to this question of how can I find a calling, it can help. It certainly beats the alternative of just trying random things and then being, you know, upset when it doesn't work out. Jennifer Toasty-Carris is a psychologist at Babson College with Christopher Wong-Michelsohn, She's author of the book, Is Your Work Worth It? How to Think About Meaningful Work. Jen, thank you so much for joining me again today on Hidden Brain. Shankar, thank you so much. It was great.
投入一些时间和精力来思考“我如何才能找到天职”这个问题，它会有所帮助。它肯定比仅仅尝试随机的事情，然后在它行不通时感到沮丧要好。詹妮弗·托斯蒂-卡里斯（Jennifer Tosti-Karris）是巴布森学院的心理学家，与克里斯托弗·王-米歇尔森（Christopher Wong-Michelsohn）合作，她是《你的工作值得吗？如何思考有意义的工作》一书的作者。珍，非常感谢你今天再次加入我的节目《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）。尚卡尔（Shankar），非常感谢。太棒了。
Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you've listened all the way through the end of the show, we're guessing you may love the topics we cover on Hidden Brain. If that's the case, please consider joining Hidden Brain Plus.
《隐藏的大脑》由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·保罗（Annie Murphy Paul）、克里斯汀·王（Kristen Wong）、劳拉·奎雷尔（Laura Querell）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）、安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）和尼克·伍德伯里（Nick Woodbury）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。如果你一直听到节目的最后，我们猜你可能喜欢我们在《隐藏的大脑》中涵盖的主题。如果是这样，请考虑加入Hidden Brain Plus。
It's our podcast subscription, where we bring you ideas and interviews you won't hear anywhere else. You can join Hidden Brain Plus with a free seven-day trial by going to support.hiddenbrain.org. If you use an Apple device, you can subscribe at apple.com slash hidden brain. Those sites again are Support. Hiddenbrain.org and Apple.co.com slash Hidden Brain. If you like this episode, please be sure to share it with one or two friends. Many people tell us that they discovered Hidden Brain because a friend or a co-worker suggested it to them.
这是我们的播客订阅服务，我们为你带来你在其他任何地方都听不到的想法和采访。你可以通过访问support.hiddenbrain.org加入Hidden Brain Plus，并获得七天的免费试用。如果你使用苹果设备，你可以在apple.com/hiddenbrain订阅。这些网站再次是Support.Hiddenbrain.org和Apple.co.com/HiddenBrain。如果你喜欢这一集，请务必与一两个朋友分享。许多人告诉我们，他们发现《隐藏的大脑》是因为朋友或同事向他们推荐了它。
Please think of two or three people who might enjoy today's show and tell them about Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请想出两三个可能喜欢今天节目的朋友，并告诉他们关于《隐藏的大脑》的事。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。很快再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。